hey everybody before we go into Episode
600 of daily V and this epic Mega Vlog
at Wine Library where I go back to my
roots and throw down for the day just
answering hours of questions um I need
to make a big announcement this is
actually the last episode of daily V an
incredible run of 600 episodes I'm super
proud of it uh going forward in 2020 in
a new decade we're going to a new format
called weekly V uh and so I'm very
excited about that format I can't wait
to hear uh your point of view when we
started daily V years ago the thought
was a daily Vlog as you've probably seen
over the last 6 to n months we've gone
away from that format as we continue to
evolve and try to bring you the most
value there is enormous confidence on
the team Gary ve and my side of how epic
the weekly uh V is going to be schedule
time really thoughtful we're going to
play a lot in the beginning but I think
we're going to find a Cadence uh of
musse TV for all of you and I'm really
pumped it's almost poetic that the last
daily V is at Wine Library the uh
stomping grounds of where my
entrepreneurial career became
professional uh I would definitely say
it started well in my early childhood uh
hope you enjoy this the individual Clips
have gone batshit crazy on Instagram so
there is [__] juiciness and I just
want to thank all of you who have
supported daily V uh weekly V is going
to be very similar but a different swing
and here is the
I see with clity I like my name was
[Music]
G me and Gary V up in the office you R
flapping walking
[Music]
through you got your
perspective I just want to be happy
don't you want to be
[Music]
happy say thank you man I appreciate it
thank you so much what's your name Bob
Bob I I own an e-commerce company a
telescope business yes and I wanted to
ask you one question as a retailer you
also talk about like cutting out like
there's not going to be any middlemen
anymore yes right the the the internet
squeezes the middle yeah it's not that
there's not going to be the there's so
many things that are squeezed by the
internet so I'm just trying to figure
out as a retailer how do you position
yourself to try to endure by becoming
the
products we have our own lab that's the
retailer has had the last 20 30 years
leverage at scale Walgreens Walmart the
model is going to flip and the producer
of the product is going to become the
Leverage point but that's going to take
real time yeah it's not like Walmart
Walgreens Wine Library are dead tomorrow
but once the capabilities of wineries um
products toothpaste every single product
in Walgreens is right now working on the
ability to make the economics work to
not be at the mercy of Walgreens yeah
but that's still going to be a 20 year
like you'll be retired before there's
going to enjoy the proc you know I mean
but the quicker you go to that place the
more likely you can
you you as a retailer have the ability
to have that brand that is a private
label go direct to Consumer and become a
bigger business than a retail store
itself Wine Library when it does Private
labels has the ability in theory to
create a private label that becomes
bigger than the Wine Library itself
under this concept okay which is the
internet yeah you mind if I just take a
picture
sure awesome awesome thanks man I
appreciate guys I'm going to I'm going
to meet everybody I just need to run
upstairs and I'll meet you on this the
second floor all right cool yes you can
have a hug Miss second floor I'll be
right there what's up
Sam how are you how's the day going hey
Jim it's always going yeah baby how are
you good to see
you all right I'll be on the second
floor in like 5
minutes oh yeah Sam you think that was
this no I know it's not you that's why
I'm asking you Sam when did this happen
and why buy you one I'll buy you one no
why when did this happen and why uh
beautiful ice creams come from Eastern
Europe and uh we started this about 2
weeks ago I've had a couple
obviously I got to go talk to the old
man and can you is Brandon on the third
floor cuz I need to speak to him he
actually on the bed
helping hey Brandon how are you
is that where hey dck do me a favor can
you like set up a spot so we can
organize this maybe you'll need
somebody's help like where do you want
me to
go this is the on the other side here we
filled all this
up what there's so many things going on
this St that make me laugh what's that
like the tables the ice cream has me
completely un
tilt the only open Real spot would be
here then that's where we should set up
why don't you set up a table
okay nobody's going to come here this is
the place to go right okay cool cool you
get a table Jeff do me a favor can you
set up a table here so I can like meet
people you organize around that I'm
going upstairs with brand for 5 minutes
yeah and I'll be back in 5
minutes what's that it shouldn't be
besides the
ice crazy I agree I agree I just saw the
ice cream and I was just like and then
the tables right there in the mezanine
Do Not Touch one of those gorgeous
tables was driving down the road the
back of truck for
p8 those are his
tables look at this come to
explosion you know the best part is some
of this stuff has been here since I this
is
really yeah December 23rd
2012 on some serious note with all this
stuff like some of that stuff like you
you understand though out of the volume
of business that we're doing and this
like it's actually pretty good yeah I
think guess how many bottles fit in here
just in here yeah I don't know how
many Hi how are you how are you to see
you good to see you how are you good
how's the kids and everything's good
what's up brother how are you to see you
good to see
you it's like 250 cases I love it looks
amazing
hello hi there you man I'm well how are
you good
good high five high five I'm always into
that what's up bro how are you good man
you well yeah W time to see that looks
great yeah excuse me
everybody Gary's going to be down in a
couple minutes when you guys talk to
them say hi get your picture taken all
that stuffff we got to go quickly move
people out there's a lot of customers
here to buy wine and they need the
parking spots downstairs say hi do your
thing every want big hug but after that
please as fast as possible make your way
out thank
you well done
Sam I don't really want know what I want
to do we're Juniors now how old are you
17 17 yeah so like you're not supposed
to know what you want to do I want to be
a personal training so good so how you
are you doing anything about it going
like college for 2 years and like move
to Florida with him he's going to go
there and do like Drop Shipping yep like
I'm going to do there like personal
train think that's be cool what do you
think would be a better idea you know
it's not about better ideas it's about
knowing what makes you happy so if like
you're doing personal training cuz it
[__] really makes you happy then you
got a chance to do it it's it's not
about is cannabis better than social
media is better than Drop Shipping is
better than Tik Tok it's what the [__]
are you about and if you're about that
then youve got a much better chance to
put in the work to actually make you
happy about it because everyone's
chasing money versus chasing the [__]
that makes them help happy or the thing
they're good at you know there's no
better there's you being more self-aware
yeah so like I don't I don't like living
with my parents like at all good news
you're about to not I I actually have a
video you remember
this holy [__] I remember this so well
oh my god dude I remember this super
well Rob Anthony listen I'm here with
Pops I have no idea why the [__] you
guys AR here we're hustling we're best
friends now and I can't wait to meet you
dude dude good dude good news like like
you're about to
move honestly you want some real advice
enjoy this little vacation called high
school cuz life's about to get real and
instead of crying about it enjoy the
[__] out of it cuz good news you're
going to be out of the house in [__]
months real
facts all right see you
fellas how are you it's a real moment I
just want how you doing bro so good I'm
sure people don't ask that much but
thank you long story
short yeah so I like I left the house
when I was 18 25 now um I've been
dabbling career to Career probably 100
different Ventures um so now I'm just
this morning woke up and I got
confirmation from law enforcement they
want me in the academy which is like
crazy I two years right for the thing is
I got a prior of marijana when I was 18
so even though I placed top of the class
top of the list for maybe six or seven
different departments that's help me
back and it's probably going to continue
to do that so my question to you is I'd
be humbled and I'd love to work with in
law enforcement but as I was going
through this whole like programing
process yeah like I made sure I on the
back end which I was looking into
medical and now Ruckers is interested in
picking me up so now is it wrong of me
to think a little bit more selfish and
think hey like yes I want to long course
I law enforcement but I your strength is
to change your mind okay that's the
strength right bro everybody thinks
changing their mind is a weakness okay
it's the [__] strength
okay that's what you want to do should
changed I want freedom essentally [__]
changed yeah you owe nothing to nobody
except your happiness okay I appreciate
it bro awesome bro than on my Jack I
can
two it's not too much
yeah two
5 yeah I figured this was going to
happen it smears on this I got a May
yeah case will definitely
work awesome bro I wish you the best bro
do what you want to dok you'll know
thing to nobody thank you what's going
on man how you doing good good BR I been
meaning to talk to for so long I'm glad
we did it you signed this sign my wallet
yet sign my w can what's your name bro
my name is Shaz Shaz yeah sh with a sh
yeah what's up where you from I'm from
Houston I actually was in Jersey for the
week for a vacation and I saw random
yeah random I got so lucky but I just
wanted to talk to about something it's
like a like a business question if you
don't mind so I'm actually doing real
estate wholesale right I whale real
estate and I get a bunch of people like
that are so mad and like when I ask them
to buy the house well we do we text like
we call a bunch of people I want to know
if there's any other type of like
marketing that you would recomend you're
in the sales business and that requires
sales the only other move you can do is
put out a ton of content that is built
to make people aware of you for them to
call you okay the problem is sales is
instant yes even though 99% are mad as
[__] at you you get that 1% exactly what
I do and what I believe in brand takes
forever but if you're willing to be
smart that you're young and in 4 years
from now like branded out of course Okay
cool so like T LinkedIn LED Facebook
Facebook Facebook ads Facebook ads in
those areas that you're targeting Crush
all right cool but don't be like hey
everybody let me yeah don't do that be
like hey this is what I do are you in a
place where you want to sell your home
and you take away that skis [__] and you
just go with the [__] real [__] and
you have a better chance of converting
all right cool thank you man I
appreciate it stay well you too man nice
me I want that dust cuz I like that
little
moment I just love the content man so
I'm here to take the picture I love I
wait for the five uniform I hope you
have the best holiday bro
yourself take care little man stay well
[Music]
bro hey got how are you follow your
content so much question yes let me sign
yeah sign the and thank
you
question H why do you like to to get
your drive again from cosic Cu uh before
I used to do like a lot of stuff C
everything doing Uber all that stuff
getting money there but then after that
my Grandpa died I went over there and it
was kind of a Ser of of events going all
the way down and I couldn't do
everything like I used to have $20,000
to to do everything but not like in in
there I canot do anything I don't know
how to find that drive again two ways
one realizing you have no other option
the [__] are you going to do sit in the
dark the rest of your [__] life so
there's that that might work for you the
other thing is just over and over and
over and over reminding yourself where
you were when you were motivated and
eventually the sadness of that sad event
and the time will heal your wound it's
one of two things [__] you what are your
other options or I love you loving
yourself and just eventually getting to
that place okay that's it one of two by
the way maybe a mix of both
I hope so but yeah it's just Mind Games
baby okay yeah it's just Mind Games yeah
I'm so nervous asking you this being in
front of you thank you very much maybe
this was you're welcome maybe this is
the
moment byebye take
care hiug you you can are good to meet
you very good I actually brought this
cuz um oh I love it yeah I have a
question for you please what would your
advice be for someone who has both their
parents divorc by the way on their
payroll meaning me so I run a coffee
shop for my mom and and not do well with
that and then now I started a
transportation company for my dad and
now I feel like my time is like being
split into building both businesses but
I don't know like in terms of technology
I feel like the transportation company I
think I think the bigger thing is making
sure both your parents know that are you
the driving force of both businesses you
need to you need to tell them to shut
the [__] up in what way if are they
complaining my mom isn't my dad isn't
but in terms of is or isn't no isn't
well then you're set in in terms of like
growth I feel like my energy could be
very well spent like growing the coffee
shop as opposed to the transportation so
tell your father that you're going to be
spending 70% here and 30% here because
you think that's right for you and that
doesn't mean you love him 20% less it
means that that's the business decision
you're making for yourself and if they
don't like it they're more than welcome
to build their own business they
I know like I do it for them I
understand well then do it then if
you're not happy it will all good but if
you're doing 50/50 when you want to do
7030 then you won't be happy then
neither of them will
win okay the way to be selfless and give
is to be happy yourself yeah I agree so
make yourself happy thank you so much
you're welcome to get really
quickly thank you so much have the best
holiday how you doing for are you so
well we met a long time ago in La I
don't even pick the video met a long
time ago in La at the friends and family
I was too scared to talk to but I've
read all all your books watched your
content for a good 6 to8 months like two
years ago back when you were this big I
have a business we did 10 million in the
last 3 years we saw football baseball
like jerseys full I'm a little nervous
but wor Appel fully customer sports
apparel really a platform all the
customers do it themselves basically go
online place that full order kind of
like a printful totally interesting yep
so what do I got to do what I got to do
to get more customers no to go to 100
million get more customers we can get
more customers but the problem is that
it's too expensive everything is too
expensive you you're not profitable on
the execution of the business right now
no well that's a
problem you can't build a business that
isn't profitable we made 300,000 on this
on this 5 million this year that's bad
yeah it's really expensive I mean our
our plan is Tech like we're trying to
the whole process we paying sales people
we're paying off people paying full-time
designers you're running a non-practical
business you raised a bunch of capital
we didn't raise any money so how are you
doing it on sales huming on sales
constant Financial
pressure raising money now raising 5
million now why are you why like where
are your expenses you like the thing
that I'm always fascinated by about
these conversations is you have to win
the game of being at least at sustained
profitability cu the second year
underwater you're you have pressure
we're under constant we're not losing
money but we're under constant constant
pressure from a cash flow standpoint
from to pay factories yeah to pay
factories make payroll I mean it's been
like this for 5 years already so sounds
like you're not running a smart business
like you either have to raise capital or
change your business
model this business used to make when
that guy ran it made 10% gross profit
when I ran it it me 23 like that was
writing a smarter business which took
pressure off super aggressive on Revenue
all we're about is revenue I'm trying to
get 50 million Revenue 100 million
Revenue even if it's not sustainable
that's that's that's what that's
something that's not sustainable loses
unless you sell
are you building it to cell yes that's
why you're going to
lose okay do you understand I understand
I don't still don't know how to move
forward but well it's you know moving
forward starts with if you actually try
to build a business not to sell you're
more likely to sell it it starts with
that you're so caught up in the startup
culture cuz you're under 40 and
everybody under 40 is 19 you're caught
up in the start of culture oh schol yeah
they're all selling they're all you all
that's why all of you lose four win and
[__] 9,000 lose 6 win and 800,000
lose you're not building businesses
You're Building Financial Arbitrage
machines predicated raising capital and
flipping not actually building a
sustainable
business cut costs of course raise
prices cut costs slow down string out
payment terms run an actual of course
you have no patience you're caught up in
the I'm going to flip the ship for a
billion
honestly bro on some real [__] cuz I
want you to win this isn't just a
motivational video this is like you have
to run a business of course cut cost of
course go renegotiate credit terms mean
of course go do pre-selling so you get
the cash flow in like real run a real
business got you know what I mean yeah
because what you're going to do now is
focus on raising Capital which going to
waste focus focus there's nothing worse
than focusing on raising
Capital you're at the mercy of somebody
writing you a check you're in a [__]
spot
versus actually building an audience and
actual business and customers who are
are a business that actually pays and
lets it sustain and grow you're in a
[__] spot and so is every kid right now
everyone's just raising Capital you're
more focused on reverse engineering BCS
than RSE engineering [__] customers
that's the market that I feel that's
what we're in right now man no it's not
what we're in it's what you chose to
look in I'm bu the [__] an agency during
this time I had the most leverage in the
[__] world 10 years ago to raise
Capital what did I build a horeshit
[__] agency it's not the game we're
in it's the game you
chose understand you do I understand I
believe you that's why I want to push
you cuz if you actually tweak it a
little bit you'll take some pressure off
will then which would then make you be
able to actually build it you know what
I mean yeah give yourself some Breathing
Room by playing a game that isn't B
based on do you understand what will
happen if the economy gets suck [__]
yeah we're [__] I know that [__]
yeah we're so don't do that run a
business that makes 10% profit 20%
profit run a business that doesn't
require you to outlay cash before you
have it tweak you can do it you
understand play a different game you're
welcome how are you brother I'm really
well finally with you thank you bro I
have some question for you yes so I have
a marketing agency I started like a year
ago I have like five restaurants for now
okay one
two but I always start some other
business with my family
they both [__] me up my both I start
with one deporting food from maon here
and they all like cancel this cancel
that and they all [__] me up every so I
I decide to not work with them anymore
smart and like do all what I can do you
so what's the question is that okay like
what should I do should I like stop
worrying about that and do my thing
100% do you feel pressure from the
family not really but are them too
much that's your problem it's over
you're
dwelling probably no not probably you're
dwelling you feel no pressure for the
family you don't have to do it you're
just upset it happened and you're
worried about the money you lost or the
trust that was broken you're looking
backwards I don't want to be mad at them
I want to continue that no I'm not mad I
told them like we can still drink coffee
that's it it's over the [__] are you
looking at last year for the best way to
not be good tomorrow is to look at
yesterday yeah the best
way that's good can story for the the
page they have for the restaurants what
they do food and things I love that
we're doing a story
yep up guys have my boy Gary here it's
me it's me it's [__] me keep pushing
thank you brother you got it bro a stay
well well my name is Eric ero real
pleasure wow I've followed you for a
while now see my older brother nice to
meet you nice to meet you bro pretty
much all our last names are romano and
we're like huge fans of you thank you
bro so I graduated as a B Medical
engineer yeah it's been 2 years since I
like I still can't find like a like a
job like I work with medical devices but
it's not a job that I see myself in the
future being a biome medical engineer
and it's I got to a point in my life
where my brother and sister um they've
been I guess
um giving the gift to like understand
their passion and what what they want
out of life and both they're they're
both in the art like field okay um and
for some reason like for me like I just
can't figure out what it is have you
tasted enough [__] um I am trying to
taste lot like a bunch of [__] right now
that's the game the biggest concern I
have for you is that you think you did
something wrong and now you're behind
I that's that's how I feel I know which
is why you're
trouble the second you think oh [__] I
[__] up and did all this and now here
I am at 24 and I'm [__] just starting
at zero you're going to lose instead of
saying where do I rank in the 7.7
billion people in the world oh [__] I
live in America oh [__] I'm 24 oh [__]
I'm healthy MH the second you realize
bro you're 24 25 great you know what I
was doing 25 stocking [__] shelves in
this
store let me just say it one more time
if you're confused what I just said do
you know what the [__] I was doing at 25
stocking sh not even in this store cuz
this store wasn't built out in a little
[__] store underneath this floor
that's what I was doing at 25
yeah bro that's it that's the answer the
answer is you're not going to find
nothing if you're still dwelling of what
got you to this
spot
if you actually said oh [__] I'm 25 I
can do for 5 years I'll be a cook for 6
months I'll be an architect for 6 months
I'll flip [__] garage sales [__] for
6 months I'll start a sneaker brand for
six if you did that and realize at 30
after 5 years of that you're still young
as [__] yeah then you
win if you're like [__] my you know I
grew up I was good at school I doing
this and the [__] you
lost word you understand that was
probably one of the best advice all I've
gotten all year that's why I get to
write the
Books pleasure bro I appreciate it I
don't want to take too much of your time
but real I just so he mentioned it
earlier I dance I'm spidering
choreographer I trying to get better at
Instagram but my main concern is how do
you not oversaturate your feet saying
you don't think the audience just
eventually just gets like got got you
bro nobody seen your [__] every time
what the [__] are you talking about
right social media doesn't work like
that right
yeah or you're thinking defense oh [__]
my core fans are going to tune out
instead of saying oh [__] if I post more
often it's going to be that one video
that takes me to the next level how many
times a day you post on Tik Tok don't
lie n n you're crazy you're [__]
crazy that's why I tell them all the
time you're crazy Tik tok's [__]
Instagram 2011 what do you like to be
first on Instagram so what the [__]
your problem it's right in your face I'm
wow okay you're overthinking
[__] that's why you write the Books
right I apprciate
it one two
5 real chance looking at your face that
you might have heard me if you actually
heard me you don't understand how
different your game's going to be
tomorrow don't
dwell the [__] does that have to do with
anything bro our grandparents generation
with the wars and came back at you don't
understand bro you [__] won you're
worried about the decisions made in high
school that has nothing to do with the
next 80 years of your
life I appreciate you know sometimes the
team's down 14 nothing at the first
quarter true and you're not even down 14
nothing you just think you're down 14
nothing I know you do I can feel it you
understand especially that's why the
context you know
go a good one take care bro Thanksgiving
thank you you too in my Facebook and I'm
proclima right now my New Year's
resolution nervous I'm sorry my idol is
to be interviewed by you not because I'm
asking but because I qualify to be
interviewed with you within the next 2
years and I think if you put me in touch
with someone that works with you and I
tell you my story and you're a big part
of it I think I'll qualify well it's
awesome a couple things so to qualify
actually means for us to reach out
versus that asking okay yeah all right
you know what I mean I'll still get
that's exactly right that's the actual
like if you really think about it in the
meta the qualifying like the version you
just brought up is the half version of
qual it's the if I can tell dck the
story that gives me the leverage the
thing that I spend a lot of time on when
you build brand is to truly qualify is
to truly just have an email from us
saying yo got it that changes your
behavior now all of a sudden you're not
trying to convince drock or Dustin
you're putting [__] in the world that
forces us to do it corre that mindset
shift is the whole [__] game that's
it Law of Attraction it will happen I
just want everyone to see it now now I
have to make it happen you have great
God bless God
bless what's up yeah let's let's put it
let's you know what pous this and this
just like put in the bottles this why
I'm going to guilt these [__] to buy
one
bottle 1000 I'm a rapper producer um
within the past two months my uh my
latest two tracks are like somewhere
around a quarter million uh streams
that's awesome and we have this growth I
just wanted to ask you how do you feel
like I can maintain that growth volume
of creative output okay you know I know
I know a lot of these things are like
love and happy holidays and affirmation
like I put out my entire thesis on music
I've not wavered people you know this
you guys know people get mad people get
mad at me for saying the same [__]
here's the answer your your ability MH
to spit it and put it out and put out a
track and put on Spotify SoundCloud
everywhere and then also make content to
put on Tik Tok and Instagram and lay
down at midnight and DM 100 producers
100 memes me different people one person
out of a thousand says yes this isn't
about this is about one person when
people hear me they're like oh I'm going
to get 10 out of 20 people this is about
getting one out of 4,000 people to do it
right right it's just that small number
that makes that difference it's what
make yeah cuz if you get the right one
person if yachty is like yo this kid's
fresh and just puts it in their [__]
it change people don't get it people
want to blow up but they want the
numbers to look like 10 out of 20 people
give me a shout out this is [__] one
person out of 8,000 right right 8,000
takes [__] 800 hours 800 hours
happens from 11:00 p.m. to 1:00 in the
morning cuz other times you got to be in
studio you got to work you got to live
right right right I did the [__] from
here in this building for 6 years with
nothing we from St field too you know
yeah right I appreciate that you got you
man well now I got some directions you
want to take a take a photo of course
I'm happy to do it thank you ban thank
you
bro awesome guys apprciate take care
stay take care
bro hey thank you for taking the time to
meet with everybody like that's big time
so I was at JP Morgan when you came and
presented and I came I I recall yeah so
this was the hoodie and I wanted to
bring you one you can have one I
appreciate it is it a medium it's a
medium I will 100% rocket 1,000% rocket
thank you bro so thank youcome so we
were so I emailed the mp1 P page and
spoke with um send an email over to John
and Nate and so just trying to like grow
the brand and but we don't want to grow
it so F like we don't want to be one of
those brands that are just like a
regular Street wheel brand like we have
like our brand like is basically
empowering people to express ID give one
second dck I have an idea I think you
we're going to do a double game because
if I go this route it's going to be
[__] the parking lot's going to be
dead so tell everybody we're doing
signing bottle picture right selfie or
whatever and then if there's question
they go back in line otherwise the whole
thing will break let everybody can you
populate it okay but you can finish go
ahead okay thank you so we're all about
like empowering to empowering people to
express identify and Define themselves
basically exactly what you talk to but
how do we keep that but still keep the
pess about us and still try to educate
people moving forward to so we can grow
as fast as we can but that was the
answer right there that it's all fast as
you can it's really easy if that part
wasn't part of your sentence yeah the
whole tell to the issue the reason I
never thought about what you just said
is because of the part fast as I can
yeah that was it there's nothing I to
say
patience bro I was in this [__]
liquor store just 10 years ago ringing
up at the register like doing this
that's like it's patience people hear it
excuse me people listen to me saying it
but they're not [__] hearing it even
in the calmness and the thoughtfulness
that you brought it still fast as you as
we can came out of your mouth yeah no it
I don't know what else to tell you but
that's the biggest truth the word fast
as I can never came out of my mouth cuz
it's the vulnerability cuz then you cut
corners which leads to less authenticity
which is game over exactly I like that
it's a trth I'm still doing it what the
[__] am I doing here right now yeah
still doing it yeah all right bro can I
get yeah of course awesome I also wanted
to show you this picture that we had it
was so funny that like I love that
that's crazy that's
awesome we get you yeah of
course ready one two
awesome awesome thank you thank you man
you got it bro take
care everything you my wife Lauren how
are you do you want me to sign that be
great y than you so much you're welcome
you're welcome I'm happy to do it where
do you guys live we're in Nashville
actually you happen to be in town yeah
we did we happen to just come through
New York and we're seeing some friends
so I love that you're welcome photo yeah
you want to go on this side yeah okay
perfect hey little guy G or girl girl
boy sorry what's his name that girl gray
oh really you never know I was called I
was called a girl until I was like four
thanks a lot man thank you yeah hope you
have a wonderful up to be inspired by it
I appreciate that thank you for saying
that bye guys have a great great great
holiday hey nice to meet you brother
nice to meet you [__] thank you
bro got it thanks for everything yeah
where do you live um I live in South
Jersey I just drove up thought you're
going to be here you can ask a question
get back in line or um I don't know um
um but thanks for everything your
content's awesome you helped me leave a
job of like 8 years man thank you so
much get rid that thank you so much want
me to yeah let me sign something for you
which one what do you drink white red or
Ros I drink red so good let's do that
the pis is epic I got you is the best
one all right I'll buy one of them too
all
right right here I got you Dad can I get
picture you can you want I'm good I'm
good I got it right there quick I have
a way you
think awesome thanks have a great
holiday what's up man what's up man how
are you nice to meet you from hun County
love that Clinton right by you yeah yeah
did you go to North no I went I'm can
hop back in line and ask a question I I
appreciate you
following got it guys for I can't wait
pH what up I'm coming back for a
question I man I love it I went to Del
too you got on the picture fry what the
[__] yeah there fry let's go
brother yeah don't go anywhere don't
come back for the question I I
appreciate
it thank you for following the mod I'll
see you guys in a few minutes thank you
for that thank you for waiting anytime
how are you great to see you thanks for
tweeting out what you did yesterday I
saw it so um are you going to be there
on December 9th where Hudson Hudson I'm
there twice a month I'm back in in hson
yard yeah yeah with over 400 your PE so
I know this yeah I know so anyway what
do you me with them for because what
happens I have the in body body
composition hold on hold on hold on yeah
so I'm with I'm in the building on the
knif perfect tell Claude I want to see
you take care the rest have a great day
thank you
care
hi of course what's his name Henry he
works for is that right y that's awesome
she's there too she'll see you on the
night
thank you thank you thank you want me to
sign
him you
go they'll taste better or you can flip
them on eBay there you
go all right one one
two awesome take
care be there I can't wait I'll see you
T night that's good G what's up bro how
are
you
thank you bro good to see you today I
know you going to be here today I was
going to event I just to stop by but I
was watching one of the videos one day
and it was like you know keep pushing
yourself consistent that's what I'm
doing right now cuz I recently just lost
my job but I've been working on my own
business going forward I love it bro
let's take this photo you got it
two a thank you man if youever yeah of
course thank you brother stay well hi
how are you just I can't believe this is
happening oh my God thank you thank you
you're welcome can we take a picture
together one two
5 that's
okay don't worry oh my God I thought
it's I thought it's a all the time we
to you so much I have books to sign up
here okay
please okay I'm
push
have this as well you got it you want me
to sign the back um sure also can we
just say that could thank you could you
confirm this is the bottle when you pour
as a church mouth but you still want to
drink a good wine is that a good
selection this is a tremendous selection
confirmed by Gary approved by Gary thank
you so much you're welcome have a great
day nice to meet you to meet you too can
I have this as well oh
yeah thank you welcome have a great
holiday what are you this is Jordan hey
Jordan I'm Kiren K how are you I st to
you so much no no seriously like sent
her a voice message she went crazy one
day you said Thank You Kristen and then
I was obnoxious and I'm like no thank
you all right where do you live in
Livingston New Jersey I love it and then
they want a new individual you got it I
don't know if I go two
three all right get in your mom oh wait
no I do want to thank you so much
because um I'm just going to say one I'm
just going to say one please you got it
you got it um Jordan yeah so I I have my
own business and it's very small but I
love it and like you validated so much
of like what I did because I quit
Corporate America but like what I just
and I know so many people probably say
this to you but like the I'm so thrilled
that you're here but but what you put
out there from your heart like it makes
me cry so sweet thank you for I love it
so much thank you you're welcome have a
great holiday are we how are you thank
you yes yes yes put yes a huge step do
you mind do you mind to do this this one
two five and this and this just my back
no no no my back one two five awesome
right here right here right here no here
I'm tell you where I want them yeah on
the floor stack I'm ghetto like that I
want to take huge step like right here
yep keep going keep I want it up to here
yep you're the one in charge I know how
you doing good to see you I I uh I just
want to say uh you're real inspiration
for me and uh what's your name Steve
Steve yeah yeah and I met you before but
like uh I [__] up the five we're going
all right one two
five thanks Steve I hope you have a
wonderful holiday stay well brother buty
picking up some Killian red I love it
I already bought $200 woro I love
it I bang out real
quick it's great to see you how you been
how you been it's great to see you again
how have you been I've been all right
I've been two to three years trying to
ask you this question I want to hear
what you think you've been in with
doctor's office you waiting a long time
what would you think as a patient in the
office waiting room if they came out and
served wine complimentary like the kind
of wine you would serve here think I
think that would work I think as long as
you gave people options for coffee and
tea and Juice coffe is there all the
time I think wine would work you think
people would like it I do I think it's a
value prop do you think I can get local
Winery wine stores like this to provide
the wine that's more of a Sasha question
all right but I mean but you think
people would be not pissed off about the
idea I think I think I think if you I
think that's
fine too
high this
good each other I think that uh I think
as long as you you make the promise up
front and people know what they're
getting into it plays I think it plays
so good to see you great to see you
great to see you have a great holiday
thank you you
too my I just want to say business and
your content is very helpful very than
thank you brother to tell you where you
from freeold about hour south I love it
two hope you have the best holiday can I
buy book yes of course I'm excited for
you want me to make it out to you yeah
sure R yeah
thank you brother have a great holiday
you got
it what's good bro how are you you're
welcome so much actually
met yeah a recall yeah I do awesome to
see I love
that thank
you I'll wait okay cool let's do a
photo
I love it I'll see you in a little
bit pleas
man
two thank you so
much we're back at 34 I'm 36 from Mars
this week just bought a bar all the
money I saved your brother I I I've seen
pictures over the years watching and I
think he got my n lock for 40 bucks and
it eats me up every day no way but but
it's I'm using that if you want me man I
love
it to
I'm you got it thanks so much thank you
yourself you tooy good afternoon how are
you Mark such a pleasure this is just a
small gift and a little note just
awesome so much I wish you the best I
hope you have a great holiday thank you
for sharing that my pleasure
take what's good bro it's honor to meet
you thank you bro what's your name
Nicholas Nicholas you've inspired me so
much I just want to thank you bro I love
all the jet swag thank do you mind
signing happy to do it happy to do it I
remember I saw as soon as I saw I I know
who it
was happy to do
it signing this and writing future owner
you got it do you think about Adam G as
the coach I'm a fan I mean I think he's
doing pretty good so far think he took a
lot of heat for stuff that he couldn't
control I mean a lot of people doubt him
but I don't they're doub they they
haven't Incorporated the injuries and
you know got you you're all said yeah
what do you need just
something yo what's good Instagram it's
Gary ve I'm here with your boy Jets love
live it happy holidays kindness always
works don't get it
flipped thank you so much you got it
bro you can
yep
good bet Nicholas thank you bro have a
great Thanksgiving all
right up what's up you me and my brother
we started our own flip business making
close to like 3,000 a week now and
everything doing pretty good I love it
congrats we got a couple of
things got you
bro mind if for get a quick photo too
yeah we met you I remember I remember it
very well as soon as I saw you guys in
the line I'm like those are those dudes
one five was that Madison yeah Madison
damn you do got a good guys I have a
real memory people sleep on my memory
give me something dust you were just
impressed I saw you all right guys take
care me and coaches Club you did yes I
know dude every time I saw your photos
wor I saw your photos the other day
actually with uh where with uh who else
was it darnold or you WR Kevin on here
this is my brother yeah he's actually
going through a breakup and you know I
kind of feel bad for him so and I'm just
going to leave him to the side because I
got a dry they're kind of yeah yeah
they're paint pens yeah see it just sign
yeah just sign the rest of them yeah I
appreciate it man got it yeah I was with
Sam uh I saw Fanatics this is so good
and I'm going to get Lev on when I go
back and coaches he's the best yeah man
I love he's good people I'm sorry to you
know hold you up and you're not holding
me up at all bro you're not holding me
up thank you for coming
all right thank you so much we take a
photo real got it one two beautiful
awesome thank you so much you got it
bro got it I'll see you Pittsburgh
looking forward to it how are you Mr I'm
well brother call me Gary nice to meet
you I'm Dave uh I've been following you
for a while on LinkedIn I have to say
you're uh the stuff that you put out
there is amazing I actually comment
every now and then but hey I don't have
anything to sign I actually just wanted
to say uh hello meet you and say thank
you where do you live in uh I just
bought a home in Denville and uh but I
grew up in Bergen County and I work
right around here all the time Scotty
several times I love it yeah you're from
Union though right or I grew up in
Edison then hun but I was in this
location like my entire 20s okay Co 15
hours a day got this is where I was
understood yeah it's awesome it's a good
State it's a little dirty but you I like
it dirty yeah absolutely awesome brother
thank you thank you right if I get a
100% cool
what's up Mike P awesome thank you all
right one two five beautiful Mike you
love this literally 40 thank you so much
40 seconds 40 seconds so nice toet such
a pleasure we're here giving some money
so nice to meet you such a fan of your
hubby maybe not as much to your level
but I'm a big fan of him she saw found
last night oh yeah saw was awesome were
great really good thank you I'm I'm used
to the camera I can get what I said oh
he's very comfortable you good yeah I'm
great I'm literally literally talking to
Nick about the Mike SE situation like
right a like 40 seconds ago um what's
great to see you guys I hope you have a
wonderful Thanksgiving spend some money
you know so I appreciate it you well
excited good pitch the other day 10 of
10 Feeling Good Vibes I got hit think
you were on the phone you heard that we
get hit by a 2x4 like 35 seconds I saw I
saw but that's part of the that's the
you know that's the subjective part that
like I'm you know I didn't mind you know
I like with people like that tough guys
like that he was good that's what he
does so we'll see but anyway I don't
want to take up your time I know you
guys how how's it to see your hubby
actually work in a place that he likes
love confused very longsuffering she's
longsuffering yes was good that was good
my children are happy everybody's happy
so it's to see great to see you Happy
Thanksgiving your healthy one okay we'll
talk to you guys
soon hello hey Daren nice to meet you
hey excellent job on jimy F thank you
bro I'm going to ask you one question
because Seth Goen told me to ask you and
David M told me to ask a question
question is is because they each spoke
for us I'm work I'm with the national
Funeral Directors Association
interesting and I know you talk about
Legacy a lot a
lot and I would love to try to have you
come uh next October I'm happy to look
at it I'm so scared about my schedule
and if I'm available no it's 18 through
20 we get through like the Monday I'll
find out if I can talk to somebody drock
will literally give you Zach madler who
runs Vayner speakers and you will
absolutely have that kind yeah cuz I
think that would be great Seth Goen did
it this year
itary you know you talk about I would
love to I would love to consider it
where is it it's actually in New Orleans
awesome happy to look at it okay all
right thanks you're welcome all right
one two five great thanks I wish you
nothing but the best yeah we'll be in
touch he's going to give you the
info what's up what's going on sir are
you uh so I just came out from oh yeah
yeah 1 two
5 I uh just came out from Brooklyn uh
literally just to tell you that it's
dope how you use your platform for
kindness and empathy instead of all the
other things you can use it for that
everybody else does but it's probably
the dopest thing and that's why you're
going to go down as one of the greatest
I'm telling BR I'm telling you I think
appreciate you seeing that man I didn't
catch your name Omar Omar it's a real
pleasure bro thank you for coming and
saying that appreciate I hope you have a
great Thanksgiving bro thank you for
seeing it of course all right bro take
care of yourself all right man great to
see you great to meet you man nice to
meet you really love your stuff thank
you so much let me sign this yeah Mar
you got it
yeah I didn't get the golden ticket so
God damn it I was really trying I know I
really wish you did on the front yeah
that's
awesome awesome thank you you're welcome
one two five beautiful awesome thank for
coming where do you live and uh Mar
County County about a half hour 40
minutes from on my own business on
travel agency we got 200 people working
for us good for you keep going love your
Stu thank you actually one of my Disney
reps is the one who turn me on to you
and he says to me he goes listen he goes
I can't really tell a lot of people to
listen to him because they he goes but
you I can next day I started watching
you and I told him I said dude awesome
thank
you Hi how are you so nice to meet you I
me before actually good to see you how
have you been I'm good how are you 1 two
five beautiful want me to sign I do I
have a question on the front
or um so I have a lot parents I'm trying
to hit teachers to a clear consistent
message teachers and parents likees the
thing is I think that's where people get
a mistake I don't think a clear concise
message is right I think there's 12
different messages that would actually
resonate with a parent and you need to
run them at scale okay some are insecure
some want them to just clean up
something some need to go to an iy
League some you know like some it's
about price some it's about convenience
I think it's a lot of messages okay and
it's finding the right segments for the
right message that's why I love social
and why television is tough for me
because it's one message it's like
multiple a day because I as a parent
versus brand as a parent versus you
versus H like it's going to be different
okay so that's why volume of content
matters that's why I put out that deck
take a look at that okay okay awesome
you're welcome Happ than you
too thank happy to you too nice to meet
you my name is Ryan Ry thank you so much
you inspired me to start a dog bandana
and beanie company so I wanted to bring
that for you dude I'm totally rocking
this I know you like beanie I will
fundamentally rock that and uh if you
don't mind I just want to hear from you
that that I've got a chance to make it
so uh I know it's all about your message
and I appreciate everything you
got awesome thank you so much man it's
the truth thank you that's the crazy
part of the internet yeah it's actually
true it's true I believe it's actually
true I kind of believe it when I say it
but I believe it when you say it Happy
Thanksgiving awesome thank you so much
man Happy Thanksgiving
Thanksgiving I'm really well how are you
nice to meet you nice to meet you bro
hey man my wife was in this line for an
hour she was so excited to meet you she
had to leave and get to work I'm so
sorry want big Superstar you was you
know everything I do thank you so it's
very everything tell tell her where do
you guys live uh Springfield oh awesome
I'll be back in the first quarter maybe
January February I'm going to do this
again excellent all right I'm Middle
School teacher any words of advice to
those kids oh God I'm so that's why I'm
putting out so much Tik Tok tell them
all to follow me on Tik Tok I'll have
them set in a
month all right one two
5es take
care
hi I love hugs actually have something
for you okay you um I just follow you
and I love you so much I you're from
Pennsylvania you're so sweet literally
oh my God you are so epic this is so
awesome thank you so much yes I know it
very well you're very's really good
because they really I just love but the
bot are good you're so sweet what part
of Pennsylvania uh from Allen Town oh I
you know I went to I grew up in huning
county in high school like super close
20 minutes away I actually when we moved
from the US from Ukraine to here I was
no kidding it's awesome all right one
two 5 beautiful thank you so much for
have a wonderful Thanksgiving yeah take
care thank you how are you good are you
good to see you you're one of my heroes
basically thank you for saying that
thank you what's your name Chris Chris
CHR CHR
yeah actually ironically I grew up I was
in the vill hotel um get out of here I
live in theill at the same time that's
amazing yeah that's I was like it's a
coincidence that's awesome
photo awesome I wish you well take care
of yourself
oh have a nice holiday yeah take care
bye
bye how good brother I'm Alex I would
love to treat you to uh root steakhous
or Broadway down in Summit you're very
sweet also um I'm a marketing major
about to graduate in May and I'm just
wondering what can I do to work at bner
media why don't you send an email to
Gary at bayner
media say I'm the kid that offer you
Ruth steakhous and more like all of it
in the title all right I saw have the
store today in the subject I email them
for an internship for this it to me put
everything in the sub everything I'm the
kid that offer you L Steak House I made
you at the store today like all that
I'll put in motion and if you don't hear
from me in a week Gary media Gary Banner
media you're the man I want to say
than you're welcome the man you taught
me so much I really appreciate it you're
the man have a great
Thanksgiving hey how's it going it's
really going well how are you awesome
I'm doing well my name isers nice to
meet you nice to meet you real pleasure
happy holidays thank you thank you um uh
thanks so much uh this last year I took
on a management position at uh local pub
they opened up like a whiskey bar so
I've been just like hustling added for
like the past like so and um a lot of a
lot of your videos and things like that
help me get through I really appreciate
it thank you bro have a great holiday
thank you so much keep
going the man thank you bro real
pleasure one two five beautiful thanks
for coming bro have a great holiday
guys have your ready what's going on man
pleas how yeah good all right one two
5ti thanks for coming through bro a
great holid have a great holiday man
thank you man thank you by the way you
yelled at me when I was in fifth grade
out there skipping karate I love that is
that true you were like what the [__]
are you doing I love it we were skipping
that's awesome bro take care of
yourself how are you fantastic you thank
you very well hey thank you you're
welcome bro one two five it's beautiful
where do you live um I'm from Atlanta
Georgia man um what are you doing inures
uh literally came to pop up and say hi
um my my mom was in uh my family lives
in Boston they came down to New York for
the weekend and I was like yo been a big
fan of stuff my biggest failure in
business like a month ago and like your
stuff's always early bro it's early can
I ask 100% could you potentially just
write happiness not your
name
and can I leave this with you you can
thank you sir you're welcome brother I
wish you well Blanc with Gooseberry from
my mom a New Zealand uh where's Brandon
where is anybody uh what's the name of
the S
mon I'm going to give it to you don't
leave I got it my guy I appreciate it
she's she's a big fan of Gooseberry and
grapefruit I know exactly what to give
you give me 37 seconds take all the time
you
need [__] I just clicked a Google ad for
one mom Gary ve is recommending this
wine it's your Christmas gift you don't
know it yet mom this one's really good
I'm super focused on it I just have to I
can't recall off the top of my head I'm
a little rusty it's going to have clar
state clar state clar state they'll have
it downstairs clar State you got it bro
what's going on man how are you Len nice
to meet you from connetic see you thank
you bro how you think
about doing good a couple couple games
now I've been fully 100% on darnold the
whole time yeah yeah yeah he could have
an entire [__] year next year and I'll
still be dude he's 6 months younger than
Joe burrow who's playing at LS
a [__] kid kids are babies out there
doing crazy [__] so me and my sister
have been entrepreneurs for a long time
I've been looking up to you I've been
doing tax sales [__] for years before I
was Kindergarten I was selling [__] to
other people tax sales going there
buying stuff but I have a great idea I
think would make wine library and the
store a lot of money well then then send
it to me send me an email to Gary at
Wine Library I'll take a look
at I wish you you too bro thank you for
coming to say
hello hi it's good to see you how you
been you've been well yes I launched a
social media company for theater good
for you two years ago partly because of
what I learned from you that makes me
very happy yeah how's it going it's
going really well that's awesome
congratulations we have I have six
people who work with us and good for you
a big deal yeah we just launched a chat
marketing arm and good for you makes me
so happy so and one two five beautiful
so just one one quick thing so once a
week I do a show where I ask artists and
Market to share what they've learned
about promoting their work on social
media okay and I'm wondering if you
would say a quick thing that you have
learned this week about promoting your
show it's called here we go video we
go I learn things daily uh this week
I've learned that way too many people
continue to not understand that the
volume of content is the enormous
variable of success and so the thing
I've learned is even though I'm putting
out a 100 pieces of content a day I want
to put out a
thousand for perfect thank you so much
you got it have a great Thanksgiving you
too have a great Thanksgiving how are
you great to see to see you o okay how
cute is this football we got to talk
about this what is it it's a t-shirt but
what a great packaging is
cool okay is that like your that's on
your mind that's your concept you know
millions
of how's the cards thing going I saw you
tast of it it's really working I BR like
this holiday really they're buying other
stuff they buy
the card market during the holiday huge
really huge I'm going to go it's the
hottest time really no this is the best
time okay yeah awesome take care Chef
have a great holiday huge honor to meet
you Jeff thank you bro it's real
pleasure thank you for coming yeah a
question um I've had a huge and like you
honestly C this I've had a huge fear of
time yes in terms of not like my
lifespan but in terms of how different
life's going to be in 20 years like I my
thought process is I'm 23 but when I'm
50 when I'm 73 my whole family is not
going to be the same people and that
scares me I think then maximize your
time with your parents and grandparents
yeah it's not going to stop time bro
yeah you can just ask you just can
execute on life yeah I Get Hype whenever
I hear you call like a 28-year-old a
baby I'm like I'm 23 I'm you're a uber
baby all right brother can I can I take
a s you can all
right actually can we do a video can
some motivation you got it bro this
isn't for your audience it's for you
you're a [__] baby you got 100 years
to live slow it down appreciate it
you're man thank you thank you brother
appreciate it hey how you doing sir I'm
doing super well hey I got this book for
you I knowk you're quotes already on it
so I know you already know about it's
from EV yep um thank you that's very
sweet I'm from Edison actually is that
right yeah
one beautiful thank you what schools uh
JPC love it I would have went to JP but
love it I passed
about I wanted to know I I know I can
help some with something um I know I
could provide some type of value to you
I want to know if I if you if I could
like be an apprentice or something like
that send me an email man it's Gary of
Vader media you got to put in the
subject what you're thinking like what's
the value prop what's the trade but I'm
happy to look at it awesome all right
bro real pleasure I wish you well how
are you I'm Jonathan hey Jonathan nice
to meet you how are you nice to meet you
guys so we just started doing marketing
but right now we're not not trouble but
time time management it's a huge deal
cuz like we wanted to hang like we also
want to make time for people we love yet
of course also make time for that comes
down to you over judging how fast your
business is
growing like if you're still in high
school and you like hanging out with
your friends family loved ones
girlfriend whatever yeah that's amazing
that also means that your business will
grow slower all right if you do 10
[__] push UPS a day versus 100 you're
going to get the results of 10 not 100
but that's okay cuz you're choosing to
hang out with each other to spend time
with your older brother I don't know
what you define by that that's okay but
your business is also going to only work
as much as you feed it okay so you just
have to have the relationship of being
patient and knowing that the results are
predicated on not only how smart you are
but also how much work you put in it's
just having a relationship of like why
is it not a million dollars a year
because you're [__] hanging out yeah
it's not complicated all right bro
you're welcome all right going
together one two 5 go ahead
sorry 1 two 5 beautiful all right fellas
have a great great great Thanksgiving so
I've been working on a little project
taking a couple hundred books and
podcasts and interviews and just
everything yep and uh compiling into one
so you wound up in there you're in the
school system chapter you're in the
entrepreneurship chapter you're in the
perspective chapter thank you John so a
lot of Gary I can't wait to see it and
these are the last of the vintage ones I
censored the [__] on the back that's
awesome I was like yeah let me let me
clean it up a little bit I love so
couple extras thank you so much all
right
ready yep oh sorry no worries at all all
right one two
5 beautiful Lio thanks a lot Union C man
love it thank you for coming through
yeah absolutely I wish you the best
thank you so much thank you for coming
happy holidays you too
definitely what's going on like it's
good bro good how are you so I'm loving
the content on Instagram and Tik Tok and
it's uh kind of prompted me to start my
own little eBay business I love it um
and I did it with a friend across the
street was also a Jets fan that's me me
my dad are both season how are and how
are you real pleasure to meet you thank
you like I've been kind of just flipping
random stuff of garage sales and just in
the last 60 days days and made like 540
bucks it's crazy right it's great it's
very real it is very real more
importantly what you're learning right
now is going to really play in the
future exactly understanding markets
understanding how to create supply and
demand understanding the grind of the
work ethic that it takes like you didn't
make the 600 bucks by sleeping in on
Saturday you had you know what I mean
all that [__] is real it's very I know
how I was built and I know what it did
and I know what it meant to create what
I've created it's my favorite thing to
teach kids not glamorous and that's why
like this prompted me to do and that's
why I'm s here so that's awesome bro
real pleasure photo yeah where do you
live uh oh love it I know West
well push me out sorry
Dad beautiful now get in here let's get
one
together good wine dad your
wine thanks for the I hope you guys have
a great Thanksgiving real pleasure would
you mind signing this I'm happy to sign
it see the man the man complimented the
line all right yeah when I think
realistically 25 years it's going to be
a little bit yeah yeah we need to stay
healthy you and I he's going to make him
a billionaire take care stay well take
care of
yourselves I'm good so I uh I'm a senior
in high school yeah I'm 17 sophomore and
junior year I dealt a lot with the
depression and was in the hospital out
my 16th birthday I SP it in the hospital
so
but I tried to channel that to football
and uh then I fractured my pelvis I
didn't tell anyone played on it for a
month stress fractured my back so it was
a whole mess and uh then it was 2 days
later and uh the marines called me so
I'm in this late entry program for the
Marines and uh I've started a
organization called will to be me so it
stands for The Willpower that it takes
to be me and then uh what it looks like
to be me so it's an acronym too Y and uh
created a podcast doing Facebook ads and
everything and uh I've helped a lot of
people so that's what up I just want to
share that with you and thank you real
pleasure bro yeah I wish you nothing but
the best happy
holidays
yeah I love it bro thank you so much
have the best Thanksgiving where do you
live Mar I love it thanks for making a
schut stay
well how are you what's up and tell
really like trash talk videos than I do
reselling myself the garage the thrift
stores and everything I love it all
right let's yeah of course all right one
two 5 beautiful what's your name bro
than angel angel have the best
Thanksgiving
bro yeah my man how are you thank you
nice to meet you course nice to meet
you to say Hi man thank you bro keeping
the kid on the hustle you know got him
on eBay doing his thing so that's what's
up bro what's your name uh Hector Hector
want me to sign something picking up for
the wife you got it
[Music]
bro nice I hope you have the best
holiday where do you live here in Jersey
where uh yeah I saw you a couple of
times on the on the garage K yeah all
right fellas take care hi good to see
you how you been I'm glad you're here I
brought my husband will you sign my Sho
100% I don't know I can take it off down
here uh pull it up yeah thank
you awesome thank you good to see you
okay good to see you too one two your
hair oh yeah the hair one
five all right let me know if you're in
River it's great to see
you how are you I mean life's funny I
just um I joined your group yesterday
and then no kidding um yeah then I heard
you were here I just want I thought I
doing a um an agency and strategist I'll
check it out you like my logo I love the
logo is it cool very cool the brain with
the fs I love it okay awesome I get to
say self-conscious no it's I need and I
wanted to do influencing and stuff and
I'm wondering if I should make it part
of my story you should definitely make
it part of your story nobody gives a
[__] about teeth that's more unique than
having them right it's your strength not
your weakness right I'm serious
drum and cuz like um I'm a carpenter and
you inspired me to start my own business
cuz I can't like my my quality in my
work I can't find somebody that's up to
my quality I love that you know
L wrapping around the here by the
[Music]
way thank you thank you brother I wish
you well thank you
dck awesome only so much I can do how
are you how are you nice to meet you
dude real pleasure how are you real
pleasure guys um first of all
gu a couple of these for your family
awesome that screws up the whole bet the
bet is if you know my company I got to
buy his book if you don't know it I
don't know it thank you very much for
this book I appreciate itop dude but you
know what's funny about me I'm the worst
like you'll ask them I don't know
anything they got 80 locations one of
them in Milburn I believe you I'm i'
you've been in Milburn now more than
I've been in Milburn you know are they
in New York City yeah got three Wall
Street I'm so [__] I don't know [__]
sorry two beautiful man thanks brother
how you guys doing where do you live I
live in Balmar Balmar bothar got yre of
the Year good for you lost but it's all
right you were there there I was there
once two and lost two that doesn't mean
Jack a bunch of private that's exactly
that's the cool part hope you have the
best thank you for coming man yeah wish
you guys well yeah take care hey bro my
name is Michael how are you I'm doing
one the most so um my brother Jonathan
Gomez is going to make the Olympics
tonight wow and so we're going to
celebrate with do you remember this one
per of course number 71 in your
collection for YouTube Y and so I'm
wondering if you could uh send the video
to my
brother what's his name
Jonathan and Jonathan here with your bro
first of all congratulations bro thanks
for representing our country oh he's
actually representing colia thanks for
representing Columbia bro cuz I [__]
love Columbia too what's good good luck
bro that's awesome is that's a pleasure
do you think we sign of course of
course it's a real pleasure have a
wonderful holiday we're like you we came
here to this country without nothing yes
now my brother's an Olympian I just
recently became a millionaire uh we
didn't speak English before now we speak
three
languages proud of you by the way I sent
AJ I made the New York Times as well I
love it and I sent it to AJ I love it
awesome awesome man keep going so nice
to meet you bro thank you thank you bro
what's up I'm Andrew Andrew how are you
I'm 28 years old I'm immigrant from from
Egypt yes so I you want me to make this
to you yeah for sure man for sure I love
you so much I love you back my people in
Egypt they all love you you you want me
to sign this yeah for
sure yeah we all love you can you give
me like a one two five beautiful thank
you I I need an advice for a 28 years
old immigrant Egypt can you can you like
record that for
me
and you're 28 and you're an immigrant
I'm Andrew and Andrew's here so that's
like you you need to remember that you
have the advantage you know the struggle
you know the grind and most of all
you're young as [__] Andrew you're going
to live for another 80 years got nothing
but time keep grinding thank you thank
you g you're welcome brother much have a
great holiday take
care I'm actually here represent my wife
gab she's from Mexico she actually knew
about you before I did she produced
and I appreciate all you do you're a
great inspiration and she really looks
up to you she has her own business name
is Gabriella you want me to make it out
to her yeah do you mind it's with one L
Gabriella g a b r i e l
a
she's l e a beautiful she's the real
entrepreneur I'm a writer it's a real
pleasure pleasure meet you have a great
holiday and and family two
beauti for her I will just wish the best
I got it Gabriella he Gabriella what's
up I'm here with your massively handsome
husband happy holidays keep up the
entrepreneurial hustle I love it I wish
you nothing but the
best thank you Tommy by the way and as
an independent author LinkedIn has been
the best for me you hi ni to meet you
nice to meet you big fan of all your
content thank you what's your name Sarah
do you want make it up to you yes
please
thanks for coming where do you live I'm
actually is that
right that's so awesome it's so nice to
meet you I hope you have a great holiday
thank
you how you doing Gary doing really well
brother how are you doing all right um I
do have a question though um he a photo
oh okay one two five beautiful okay all
right um I was just wondering how how
important it is to convey to uh like
potential employers like um how
important like Independence is cuz like
that's the way like I live my life what
do you mean Independence so like doing
things on your own like you know
figuring it out for yourself I mean so
an employer yes I want like like I just
want to know like how how important do
you think an employer will frown on that
because you're not focused on the job
yeah it means nothing okay all right it
means nothing half the employers will
think it's the worst and and that will
be a problem and they won't hire you and
half will be like me and don't give a
[__] and they'll hire you gotcha don't
overthink it all right well I appreciate
it care pleas have a happy holiday how
are you how you doing good to see you
you you mind finding this of course how
are things good good how are you very
good that's a nice one yeah of course
you want to
thing two beautiful have a great holiday
my friend when you going to own 25 years
firm all thanks a lot you want me to BR
I'll do it what excit it all right cool
how are you how you doing thanks for
coming bro where do you live I live in
Jersey Scotch Scotch will thank you got
it bro take care commun and everything
yes some stuff online a buddy of mine uh
he's a travel worm whatever he always
looks up to all your stuff you to and
everything just inspirational thank you
brother hope you have the best holiday
brother stay
well what's coming how going bro how are
you I'm good good doing well thank you
for coming no I appreciate you man thank
you thank you so much bro real quick so
me and a CLE Place have a cry therapy
business um cry therapy has been super
awesome especially with popularity and
attention Joe brogen everything doing it
it's died down a lot it's and it's going
to die down more yeah okay so what was
your plan of attack that that was my
plan of attack is never be in The Fad
business yeah so you you need to
recognize that it's declining and do you
have a location we do we do we've been
adjusting with different products you
know more like health and beauty
like and it's been helping us this used
to be a liquor store selling no wine
yep wow yeah I know what else to tell
you right here this sold liquor and beer
now it's [__] 98% wine that's awesome
you got to adjust go the box is the Box
yeah what you put in it is the variable
of success yeah appreciate that awesome
man thank don't do what most people do
is they're like [__] we bought this
machine and they try to [__] they
don't give a [__] that you bought the
machine right right I don't give a [__]
that you bought the machine I don't want
the cryotherapy
you got to adjust to the customer not
where you put your money absolutely y
awesome man appreciate it man man thank
you what's up brother how you doing man
crazy for me thank you bro happy
holidays thank you so much I'm a
two thank you so much so I'm a 17year
old entrepreneur um I I'm big into Tik
Tok influencer marketing so I have a
company called tifi that basically I got
it I know what you're going do yeah so
you know what don't become too
onedimensional because if Tik Tok
becomes Vine and a year from now but so
make sure you do all the other platforms
too but lean into Tik Tok well the thing
I was doing I was like focusing big time
because um cuz it's hot because it's hot
but I'm not really worried about it
dying down because like when it when it
does die down I'll just move on to the
next thing except you're called tick AI
correct and so that's where a lot of
people get caught with names make it
more broad got it not the tick can't
mean all influencer so I'm not that
worried about it but but recognize that
every customer is going to hear tick ay
and think you're Tik Tok got it not
Instagram not YouTube not podcast so be
thoughtful about that got that so much
well have a great day what's going
on see Hi how are you it's nice to meet
nice to meet you
two two five that's how we count that's
it um yeah I just wanted to thank you
for all the content you put out and the
free [__] you put out on your birthday
it's dop thank you and I'm a high school
business teacher so I'm not really in
like pure business realm or and I don't
consider myself anre or anything but I'm
going to Real Estate and Property
Management cuz I know Property
Management in Jersey so I'm trying to
take that broader so I'm really pumped
about all the stuff you put out than you
for it thank you stay well have a great
holiday what's going on man hey brother
how are you pretty good man how 1 two
five what's your name Angel Angel hope
you have a great Thanksgiving thanks
meet
you thank
you thank you having the best holiday
take care have a great holiday how are
you nice nice to meet you hi nice to
meet you all right 1 two 5 beautiful
where do you guys live uh Fairfield New
Jersey awesome thank you for a good
drive yeah pretty cool to meet you thank
you hope you have the best holiday yeah
what's the key to staying consistent of
whatever you're doing doing [__] you
actually like not things you think will
make you
money sense if you don't like to do it
you're not going to [__] do it I was
the laziest [__] ever when it came to
school I'm the most consistent [__]
when it comes to entrepreneurship when
people chase money and they're in
cannabis or crypto or social media or
T-shirts they lose cuz they don't love
that [__] they try to chase money when
you love what you do you're consistent
as
[__] awesome time at Bitcoin
sure this side you got
it you're
32 jeans yeah um I'm more like 33 right
now cuz I'm
fat see you
I wish I was 32 good to see you bro nice
to meet you two questions can sign some
baseball cards I sure can and I got
jeans for you thank you bro pair of
jeans you sure can I'll rock them too
size 32 or
34 they're going to look sick
Cal I'll take them both you want both
yeah dude you this way this way I
actually wear them in case I pick the
wrong thing I love it bro I totally Rock
them when you see me rocking them in
content reply and I'll be sure to share
it probably that'll be I'm happy to do
it can I get a picture of you up
yeah right one two five beautiful Beauty
yo best holiday bro take happy to do it
Happy Thanksgiving same to you bro have
the best thanks
Meers
fivers real pleasure hey I'm from GH
right we have something called jilles
which infanty wine would go with J
probably the white the white yes you
know J I do I've been to go multiple
times I built schools there there's a
great YouTube with me and Ghana that you
have to watch yes type in Gary B and
Ghana okay absolutely one one one more
question so when you go to the gym you
get a trainer right yes they give you
instructions you follow through all of
it with the goal in mind right you hit
that goal because you follow every
single step now for entrepreneurship is
there something like
that got it for me too
great that's why most people aren't good
entrepreneurs people can follow models
the market moves too much right it's a
mindset and then an execution just like
working out is you can follow a model
but if your mindset goes you're going to
fall hey thank you you're welcome
bro I wish you well happy
holidays yeah hey how you doing I'm
doing too well Carter Carter nice to
meet you yeah I uh love oh actually do
you mind signing this first I I'm more
nervous than I should be but seriously I
bottom of my heart thank you man you you
unlocked everything I need for the rest
of my life seriously means the world to
me beautiful means the world to me BR no
absolutely just keep doing what you're
doing I will I'll be here to support I
wish you nothing but the best happy
holiday thank you man for sure behind
that thank you bro thank you bro it's
pleasure to meet you nice to meet you
bro everything you've done really
appreciate Wayne texted me today did he
really my dad's favorite player I knew
you'd appreciate this he best
two I was wondering if you could
actually sign it happy to do it happy to
do it thank you very
much question for we do we do a podcast
together it's about we're both
Georgetown people so Georgetown
basketball what's as far as content we
took a look at your model we were
actually going to later to brainstorming
what typical tips the mock the mo I gave
you 7 [__] pages of decks [__] do
it I gave it to you do it all right all
right what's your favorite M one I'm
getting one for my girlfriend hopefully
the red is Bonkers like [__] Bonkers
hopefully girlfriend I love that good
luck because did the hard work all right
good good luck
take to see youen I do of course I do I
know you're to see yeah yeah I to come I
don't even tell Scott he's going to love
the
photoing everything good everything's
good happy yeah I don't want to keep
worries I'll be I'm going to send you
I'm going to send you a note pleas you
want you say maybe meet up I know you're
a busy
gu thank you brother take care yes sir
hey Gary got a good question for you
brother I love your stuff online thank
you let me take the photo
first I'm CTO for a postquantum
encryption company we secure people's
systems and data against quantum
computers and everything that comes
after that understand give advice for me
we're about 30 people now right down on
how to grow Top Line on how to just get
some market shares so were're a
successful startup about 30 people
LinkedIn marketing at scale at scale
targeting decision makers CFOs CEOs cios
uhhuh volume creative against them hey
you know here's the value prop here's
content around what they I would take a
total framework of did you know you know
your business is very good at selling
fear which I would do and then also
building awareness but it is LinkedIn
all the way I post a lot of stuff on it
already running ads against who you're
targeting when you know you're targeting
a CFO of a company and saying this will
save you money the ad and the creative
will convert better than just
organically posting on LinkedIn and you
guys do that first we do at the Sasha
group level if you go to the Sasha group
and talk to James the Sasa group we'd
love to have you come up and see our
offices we're right in the Freedom Tower
so thank you take care of yourself back
all right bro thank you for being
patient yeah any time producer DJ
podcaster not in that order I know
you're going to tell me about artists
but I want to make a specific question
we have a collective of artists that are
you know from Jersey we all come
together do open mics together but it's
like a crew yeah so from the marketing
side though what can we do to leverage
all of us together you Market together
and you've seen this already right like
Jake Paul's thing and others like this
is out there fa Clan like Market as a
crew Market individual be the X-Men and
also be Wolverine so does that mean make
songs together make music videos
together make all this yes and put all
the instead of being cuz I think you
know artists that always want me me me
there's Avenger movies there's Iron Man
movies yes got it both there's X-Men
movies there's Wolverine movies the
answer is yes both yes both always it's
always the [__] answer awesome That's
it man thank you so much appreciate it
wish you
man yes Dustin way to be on that one
that's a good one around buddy what's up
it's all good how are you well so I
started my first company at 16 years old
uh I worked like three three months as
like a janor in my school quit that so I
started a mobile car detailing business
go to my customers houses and go right
there their driveway um recently
graduated college Finance degree yep
really don't want to do anything with it
so I'm back to doing the detailing I've
only been listening for like two months
now and it's like helped tremendously
thank you I just want to know like what
the next step would be to grow my
business you know well it's either Word
of Mouth from the people you've got
right if you've got money you run ads on
Instagram and you know it's it's really
simple like all my model I know it's
only been 2 months but what's crazy
about me how this place was built how my
whole career was built it's just the one
ingredient that everyone's missing is
patience right right when I was your age
I was in this store on this day in the
basement and they would call down and be
like a customer wants Budweiser a case
of Budweiser and I would grab it and put
it on the conveyor belt that's literally
what I did in these [__] spots at
your age that's not what this crew wants
to do they want to be [__] Elon Musk
at 22 I was willing to eat dirt for a
decade most kids aren't the answer to
your what's next is a fuckload more
detailing right until you build
reputation trying to like acquire
customers that's kind of my hardest part
Facebook Instagram like I put out
content for free every day on this
that's not the hard part the the hard
part is being patient M the hard that's
not the hard part bro yeah yeah I'm
putting it out for free it's not the
hard part right I know it's not I know
it's I'm right it's you know everyone's
like the hard part like the hard part is
going in the gym no it's not you know
exactly what [__] workout to do you
know how to eat well nobody [__]
wants to eat well and go to the gym
every
day no that that's why the diet industry
is unstoppable that's why people take
[__] celery juice and apple cider
this and [__] waste that and [__]
steroids in your [__] lips and
[__] ass implants nobody wants to put
in the [__] work that's the hard part
the hard part aren't the ads I [__]
told you it's I started I started for
free on Facebook there's a community
page hun ladies with hunting county is
called where it's like here's here's
what's free you've heard it from me it's
called LinkedIn and Tik Tok I've been
telling you it's free car detailing
crushes on Tik Tok free that's not the
hard part bro I want to detail your cars
okay I don't even think I have a car I
just have Obby an Uber right thank you
bro can I you you can you tell your car
you can do bro I don't have a car get a
car I hate
cars free Tik Tok and Linkedin is free
like Facebook used to be thank you Mr
vaynerchuck Sir right quick I signed
that already or not can I can I sign it
front or so U inside or on front
actually yeah so my question is this in
2017 I ran I opened up a company a
construction business and my question to
you is when you were oneman gig with
Vayner media yes it was very smart of
you to start with big companies like JP
Morgan and Toyota how I didn't start
with them Toyota Toyota came in in year
six JP bgan came in year seven oh so was
it B to C for the first six years no it
was it was we cuz we're a B2B company
only okay so who how did you know who to
talk to especially if big organizations
I don't forget had already built this I
wasn't like you I'd already built this
so I had reputation companies knew I had
half a million followers on Twitter
understood so I wasn't in the same spot
got but the thing that I see works is
content got you putting out content on
LinkedIn and showing your smarts leads
to people reaching out to you or cold
calling it's just selling or branding
okay thank you it's patience I really
appreciate it it's patience yeah I just
want to get in front of the big guys but
it's just like so email them I do and
there's how many don't [__] [__]
me okay dick email a th000 people a day
and then wait seven years I know I'm
right go put in the
work what's going on man what's good bro
happy holiday how you doing um so I just
wanted to gift you with a gift damn dude
this is fresh as [__] hey man appreciate
it I'm all right I I don't know how you
guys are getting home but I want this in
the office I don't want to lose this
who's going to do it oh Obby we'll do it
Obby we'll put OB we're good we're good
yeah yeah yeah sorry sorry I got excited
I love this
[__] got it it's fresh bro you did this
dude this is really fresh bro so I'm a
drill instructor in the military um law
enforcement as well so I'm like dud this
is super this is super smart penny is to
remind us there's something here there's
something here are you only doing
pennies no no so I do all types of art
dude I think the penny thing is super
interesting there's I think where the
world's going is like like honestly I
think this line has way more to do with
humility than it has to do with bravado
or confidence or success there's
something about pennies that like speak
to it absolutely there's something there
absolutely I'm going to give that some
love and I'm going to tag you all right
can you D you'll get his handle you'll
follow him right now
what's what's your handle get him uh C i
r eore b okay yeah definitely I
appreciate Happ Hol bro stay well take
care where do you live um in North I
love it thanks for coming
through
sorry and you're on hello hello hi
Epiphany epip a beautiful thank
you how are I'm doing well good awesome
thank you for com thank you so much hope
you Thanksgiving I would it's actually
really tough tomorrow everybody's like
Thanksgiving it's actually my
grandmother's birthday and she passed
away and I'm sorry to hear that sorry I
was trying not to get emotional but one
of my things of vulnerability getting
through it fighting through it still
feeling it and everything and we
celebrate her life I am and that's what
I like you her it's like she hasn't
really get gotten to see me grow to this
point and really yeah she's watching
like my guardi so I'm so excited to like
be able to represent that for her and be
able to push forward and just show up
for her like my thing is show up show
out show off and it's Epiphany with the
a a p p i FF a n n y just in case you
didn't get it but um I'm really excited
and also I wanted something cuz you were
also here to give wine advice like
something that like really represents
her cuz she's like bold she loves red
she was like a red wine person something
bold flavorful and like what do you want
to spend spontaneous um and she was like
mid-range like then let's do this yep is
16 okay yes good all right let me S it
too easy well this I'm
to thank you very much for coming come
with a lot of gratitude today I love
your videos everything you put you put
one out there that was just incredible
and you said get off your ass save some
money for the future you got a safe
future we you motivated us first of all
this is in Jet's color we wrot we wrote
this book because it's the only book
ever written about 401K investing
intended for the employee for the people
of the world I love that so that's for
you thank you very much you take a quick
shot all
right I know there's a shitload of
people big ass there anyway you just
send a message to say I don't like
endorsing things I haven't done the
homework on but I'm happy oh just in
general they got to that's
all everyone listen to me listen to me
good saving money for the future always
works it might not be the biggest bad
right now but saving money needs to get
cool stay well take care
I'm Ali from Livingston nice to meet you
I'm a college professor it's a real
pleasure to meet you he I grew up in the
area I love that my students up until
two months ago I didn't know who you
were until two months ago my students
were like you're so Jersey you're just
like Gary bayner Chu like who's that for
the past two months I've been listening
to the gas Gary V show I thank you and
it really helped me with as far as like
scaling and thinking about as a teacher
how to kind of not only yeah kind of
like you know grow think also number two
that whole thing about what are you
doing from 600 to midnight on like damn
that's serious um thank this isn't a
this isn't a one
two this isn't a jab or a right hook but
I'm a professional writer as a professor
so if you ever need anything on the
writing side I love that thank you I'll
save it we sometimes do awesome to meet
you have a great holiday thank you
happying you got it are my man how are
you nice to meet you man it's a real
pleasure pleas big fan thank you 1 two
5 com so we're out to dinner last night
we go to Benny Hana take the kids yes
we're all there four kids right we all
at the table thankful uh the whole
sitting down you know once of a month we
go out entire Jets team walks in no
kidding all Jets fans now I love that
and they start winning and I'm like
and man I wish you well have a great
holiday where do you live ch ch how's it
it's going real well very nice such a
pleasure so first of all man I [__]
love you you're awesome as [__] man like
I kind of had to like cut all my friends
off because they don't have this
mentality you know I love I love where
you're coming from good question so 20
Scotch PLS actually I go to school in
Philadelphia my boss told about you like
oh [__] he's supposed so I had to come
home but now they H there so 20 I
actually just got into pharmacy school
I'm trying to be a pharmacologist okay
and I also actively trade on the stock
market which requires a lot of work and
I'm also trying to get my first property
so I can flip it it out now it's a lot
of [__] going on so I feel like whenever
I I'm studying I'm taking time away from
stop that's that's that's the mistake
and you need to be I always talk about
if you're juggling 10 balls it's okay if
two drop because you're still juggling
eight okay you've got a whole world of
people doing nothing yeah you're trying
to do three things so if you're doing
one and the other two are slouching you
know you're just studying for a test as
soon as you're done with that you can go
back to take it back people are judging
themselves like oh I'm dropping this
instead of focusing on I'm doing this
you need to flip the perspective you're
not dropping you're [__] achieving
glass at full 100 okay I respect that's
it also last question what
this what keeps me motivated is bro what
keeps me motivated is what's the
alternative okay yeah like what else you
doing life I'm Waking every [__] day
I love you so much man thank BR take
care yourself thank
you Hi how are you nice to meet you nice
to meet you how are things good good I
just want to say that I'm really happy
you're live my $100 bill too get out of
oh sign it that scared me sign it I'm
like not taking your money um and I want
to say that really happy you're live and
I'm a marketing manager and I'm
literally doing so many trainings based
on your teachings that makes me so happy
it's crazy like a dinosaur company for
the first time in 50 years like they're
innovating I love it and it's like crazy
like things are really good things are
happening in the company and my boss
every couple days he's always like I'm
so immensely um uh glad that you're in
my company the first time they they they
hire somebody young too so it's it's
great it's great thank you have a great
holiday thank you so much can you sign
also one one one one one bottle yeah
thank you you got it I'm I'm I'm so
happy that you're doing this stuff thank
you take
care oh yeah yeah that works too please
uh how do I hide this oh not some what
do you want hide hide what hide this
fine you want me to hide it and one two
five one more
Beau thank have a wonderful you you okay
D getting tired cring a little too much
camera
time hey how's it going really well
pleasure meeting you meet you my name is
Eric yes Eric um and it's you know it's
so funny cuz every time I wake up in the
morning I look on Tik Tok and you're the
first one that actually pops up that's
good and uh that means we're putting in
the right work we're doing it right you
know and this uh and it's always been
Kim nice pleasure just to be here and
just to meet you in person uh we
definitely admire all the things that
you're doing thank you so much you so
much have a great holiday take yeah of
course
two awesome take care I apprciate have a
great
holiday good
one Dustin look behind you take
care really nice meeting you nice to
meet you I've been following you for
years now moved from from Brazil to
America right you're the first person I
followed and you've been sping me for
many many years thank you my friend
what's your name
e 1
two awesome thank you my friend hope you
have a great Thanksgiving thank you
where do you live I live in uh Hillside
awesome like real close real close take
care bye-bye hi hi nice to meet you nice
to meet you how are love you are thank
you amazing thank you all right one two
5 beautiful thank you for coming thank
you I hope you have a great Thanksgiving
thanks for coming
byebye
hiim austral nice to meet you from
Australia how you doing what's your name
John John what part of Australia Sydney
syney Sydney I know it quite well to see
you down there and we where to go unbel
s years ago we both read to crush it
right she started her own Global Fitness
business five different countries now
brilliantly I left a job as a CEO
corporate world jumped out had my own
Consulting business we just want to say
thanks yeah thank cuz you had like a
massive impact
that makes me so happy two and they want
IND we get a
separate they're all yours no seriously
man like I hope that you
realize I realized quite a bit but as
you can imagine it's so overwhelming
it's overwhelming like I'm looking at
you and like seven years ago we read
your book and now like wow you know I
mean we work seven days and we we around
the cuz you're happy cuz you're happy
cuz you're happy yeah it literally
brings it's I'm humbled and I will
always be humbled and you're always
going to hear these stories right CU and
and it's what I'm it's what it's what I
want I want the admiration I want the
Legacy and she's doing the same thing
with other reading her book and when you
put in good good scales man thank you so
much have a great holiday take
care pleasure meeting you man dude I
don't even drink alcohol I literally
just came here to ask you a question all
right so my dad was the one who
instilled the mentality and me that like
anything is possible so I've carried
that with me throughout my life but he
passed when I was 16 so and the thing is
like I know it is it is and I understand
that's like but I learned a lot from
that especially being grateful one of
the things you taught right so I'm at a
point now where I kind of I graduated
school k i m y k i mm y yep I graduated
school uh I'm working the job right now
thankfully um and of course I'm trying
to pursue entrepreneurial things but
mentorship is one of the things I find
I'm lacking right now especially being
that the mentor I had passed away so
what would you say a good source to find
mentorship is you know even when my
friends right now I find you ask people
cold 100 500 people you admire or you
get a job where you get so close to the
CEO that she or he can be that Mentor MH
that's it ask or get a job that doesn't
and what about with friendship because I
find it forward to find friends who are
like likeminded with thaty you're
looking the wrong places there's a
billion [__] like you mhm appreciate
it man take a picture real quick one two
five you understand yeah less analyzing
more
doing Hi how are you good how are you so
well so yesterday I was thinking of
something clever to ask you right cuz
you answered everything so I was going
to say why don't you never text me back
and then you texted me back yesterday so
now I have
question all right one two five
beautiful thank you for coming live um
Wharton I know it I know it all right
take care hi Hi how are you you can
oh my God I'm so excited I have a
question photo first you
can thank you do you have any advice for
so I just went solo I'm a massage
therapist um I went solo at the same
time that I want to get pregnant which
is really wild do you have any advice
that you prepare for both because now
I'm pay for my own matern do not over
judge yourself okay that's the key that
is of course it's the key if you start
beating yourself up if you're laying
there and saying why am I so stupid why
would I leave right before I got
pregnant or wanted right you're going to
beat yourself up and you're going to go
negative the reason you did it even at
the face of pregnancy is cuz you weren't
happy and you wanted to be happier yes
root for yourself instead of booing
yourself okay I love it thank you take
care that was a good
one
I'm um I have two questions one personal
for me and then one professional so
professional uh work for the company
which is a construction company compan
of North Carolina you know house design
Consulting Custom Homes home remodels so
they've been in business since 1979 but
really join social networks just
recently CU they don't really believe
that so I sort of started that with them
and joined LinkedIn less less than a
month ago so how do how do I gain
following I know you know I'm not trying
to like get thousands of followers cuz
I'm content or running ads properly it's
always the same answer okay you know the
model it's more about what are you going
to say and the key is knowing how to
bring value to the prot potential people
that you
want like who would follow the company
and then why and once you answer those
two questions you
win what one more who who would follow
your company and why okay who you know
cuz it's the customers that poent right
why the reason I the reason this line
exists is cuz what I do
there's a lot of people that have a lot
of followers but they're putting bikini
pictures in there they're making joke
videos they're showing them making a
basketball shop I'm [__] put out in
content that changes people's lives
that's why that
happens Wine Library if it posted just
by this wine wouldn't win if it said
this is how this wine tastes and that
helped you learn it's about what you put
out got it yeah thank you you're welcome
um what is what do you think is number
one quality in
period yeah kindness kindness okay thank
you could you oh my god thank you I
didn't expect it hug um could you just
say to keep my bosses accountable Gregs
and Company you go fresh Gregs and
Company Gregs Gregs can you say spell it
for me oh GG got it got it yo Griggs and
Co keep crushing it patience and bring
value to the customer don't worry about
the
numbers oh my God thank you so much I
really appreciate it thank you Gary take
care byebye
I've good to see you bro yeah dude thank
you for existing in my lifetime I'm so
I'm son of a [__] man thank you bro
definitely all right one two
five question how often do you adjust
your end in life like how much the
market
changes the end game never just trying
to build Legacy okay I just daily my
actions because the market changes the
market changes but the end game has you
never like final goal or the final goal
is to bring as many people so much value
that every one of these [__] shows up
to my
funeral the end game's been easy be back
take care
bro how are you uh so you know I just
turned 19 gratitude patience all that
you know one thing I do struggle with is
uh you know I I decided I have to go to
college uh so like you know how do you
find like the right partner relationship
that way financially and like mutually
it works out all that from a b business
standpoint uh just you know finding
someone that someone as a a a life
partner yeah uh by by not like that does
that almost broke my mind because the
thought of the thought of over woring
about finding a life partner based on
the fact you didn't go to college is
ludicrous there's a drillion people that
would marry somebody who didn't go to
college you you just think it's an in
you just see it see as a vulnerability I
view it as a
strength millions of other people view
it as a strength they'd be willing to
marry you that you're
welcome two
5 stay Thank
you
right man say first off thank you very
much you're welcome uh all the
information really helped me a lot 1 two
uh yes just want to ask you so I've been
do I'm a music producer doing it for
like five years uh just this I make
electronic music just this year yeah uh
just this year uh got signed some big
labels now it's kind like every song few
hundred, views you know it's it's a
start You're Building yeah so I just
want to know uh like I want to be you
know get my songs to the millions of
views really do what got you from zero
to
100,000 like what else could I do like
what uh put out more [__] put out more
bangers consistently yeah and then let
the market take over all right just keep
doing what I'm doing I'm literally doing
the same [__] right now that I did when
I was sitting upstairs making videos for
YouTube in 2006 putting out the best
[__] [__] that can come out of my
mouth to the World on the websites that
matter at the moment go Tik Tok matters
yeah you uploading a ton of content with
your music on Tik Tok [__] matters
okay yeah you understand yeah I don't
even use Tik Tok I don't it's a big
[__] mistake I'm about to get on that
when I go home like you leave like run
get out of here all all right
okay that too how are you you or just
sign it uh just to me yeah that' be
awesome s uh scn or actually you could
do is a p Cho so that's like P Chico pH
uh p a p a yeah and then it's c h e e k
o p a c h e e k
o so for somebody for me I want
to not only take my music very far but I
want to use music to take um a lot of
businesses so where do you see first you
need the leverage of the music to matter
to help a business or the business
aren't going to give a [__] so first
focus on the
music so like I have this one thing I I
wrote in one of my songs it's music is
my plan B what's my plan a you're going
to see so it's like um how is it that
like so I want to start a business first
so like I can go into the music game
already with I I wouldn't so what's your
business I want to start like I want to
open up like a smoothie shop something
healthy to where like the old ladies so
how you going to do that forget about
philosophy and like what you want how
the [__] are you going to open the smoy
shop I know he's just working hard to
save money right now good um that's real
good [__] answer bro cuz I didn't
think you were going to give that good
of an answer that's good yeah but I just
feel like I I work a lot and I've been
working for so many years and I see
myself on such a different Spectrum
every day I dream that that's me too I
did too right here right here on these
[__] Hollow grounds
my question is what's the
problem I just feel like I know what you
feel like like four months ago was in
the same spot that I [__] 4
months how old are you 20 bro you're
going to get it from me on some real
[__] like that's just you're going to
lose if you talk about 4 months at
20 why don't you save money for 6 years
open a smoothie shop at 26 have it
successful from 26 to 32 and then put
out [__] music at 32 too but I know
you're not thinking that you're not
thinking 12 [__] years or or can I
work on music like the whole time you
could work on music the whole time of
course you can if you're not spending
time on dumb [__] no so of course you
can you know you can bro this is the
same game for every 20-year-old deeply
impatient I know I'm right everybody
wants it now everybody wants a prove to
everybody they made it it's all about
worrying about everybody else I didn't
give a [__] when I was in this store my
friends were 27 and I was still in a
[__] liquor store I didn't give a
[__] that's why I won cuz you knew where
you were going to be in that's right
well guess what you claim you know where
you're going to be and so I want you to
be [__] patient instead of talking to
me about 4 months at
20 take you
bro one
two stay well take care bro
dust nice to meet you real pleasure
thank you for everything you do man this
year has been my best I would love that
[__] bourbon too go ahead uh I need a
case of wine for my clients how much did
I get what do you want to spend 300
bucks this this [__] stuff is crazy
this is like 42 bucks a bottle it's $1
199.99 so 240 a case sounds good to me
you got it Sam show me needs a case of
booty right boy y awesome if he needs a
club card you'll help him with a club
card if he needs it yeah you got it Jo
you got it thank you awesome that man
awesome I appreciate that thank you have
a great holiday all right 1 two 5
beautiful enjoy it stay
well what's going on Gary life is good
how you doing man real good brother how
are you life fantastic dude thank you
one two
5 where you from I'm actually from uh
Stockton just outside I know it I know
it super well I went to North High
School it's such a beautiful area I just
love being here and thank you I'm glad
you're here like it just keeps getting
better and better
I was in a really dark place like a long
time ago coming out coming out of that
makes you grateful makes you so grateful
dude gratitude is everything you're free
it's literally everything the thing is
like my brother wasn't able to make it
today and I just like I wanted you know
some words of advice cuz he's kind of in
like a what's his name uh Sean Sean
yeah I got
you Sean when you flip it upside down
and see all the good instead of worrying
about what's not life gets [__]
popping bro join us over here bro join
us [__] over
here thank you so much man I really
appreciate it Happy to do take care
brother great to see you how are you
good man good you sign this for me 100%
let me send a box first awesome thank
you you need more now I think so I
didn't like the the way that black just
worked thought I had oh I've got it I've
got it I've got it only have good oh the
dark clouds yeah I've been hold on than
for Mom's for
this thank you dude you're welcome dude
hope you have the best Thanksgiving ever
you to and I got to I got to thank you
dude like I started flipping over the
summer yeah
$15,000 dude I'm trying to dude $15,000
in 6 months is Bonkers it's all there
people don't want to hear me well I did
it in in my plan is to basically take
everything I made off the flipping save
it to put into the company of course
everyone's like Gary how do I raise
money I'm like don't raise money
[__] make money but it's been
everything plus you're learning bro
you're learning too when you start
learning Arbitrage and marketing and the
copy and the eBay photos it [__]
changes you dude has been a gift and now
that it's cold out I've been using
Marketplace so like I have to thank you
dude really yeah proud of you bro good
[__] five beautiful thank you brother
appr stay take care of yourself
that too D all of it [__] it we're hot
[__] it thanks for
waiting
yeah
people
taking did you like love
itup
going Community y um and looking to
engage with them outside
so what's the question i'
rather do you know of any social
platforms or any types of Messengers
that CU I have an idea here that I'm
thinking about
musing consider even like you what do
you mean like there's this company
called
D every conversation prevent screenshots
complete control direct I don't think
people give a [__] about that they don't
nope they don't no okay so what do you
nobody does in terms of privacy is the
fakest conversation in the world really
really okay so what do you
recommend direct contact you man
something like that one-on-one texting
yeah yeah but with like this huge group
this you can do this yeah this will work
Community the app I'm using when it
opens up will work and so will the other
50 platforms that are about to come out
that are going to do direct chatting
cool and WhatsApp telegram yeah they all
[__] work even like privacy side
nobody gives a [__] about
privacy I get a
video yep
sure whatever you want to
say yo on some real [__] I'm going to
meet a million and one
people thanks so much take care bro stay
well Gary it's been up F how are you
good you want to sign my wine carrier I
do let me go with
like what should I get
youing this I'm like do this what you
should I be drinking this uh this
holiday what do you like to drink like
Pinos the Keller penino downstairs is
Bonkers Bonkers Keller this is
phenomenal [__] I don't know how much
this is but I'm in love how much is this
give me two how much is it probably 40
something it's it's can you find out how
much it is I'll take two of them and you
can sign one oh
will
but uh what do you think about LinkedIn
can it be monetized meaning like I got
like a lot of followers and work
technology everything can be monetized
it depends on how you monetize yeah but
I don't know how because they still P me
a subscription yeah but like but like
LinkedIn is not like like meaning
meaning is LinkedIn going to monetize
are you going
to are you going to be able to monetize
the LinkedIn that they don't stop you it
depends on what you ask them for I think
they do because they do limit sometimes
what you try to stream certain and then
ask if I try to get like some if I can
build a subscription model for people to
pay me for the content I push to them
not on LinkedIn yeah that's your problem
yeah you got to take them out of there
so I can I start doing it on LinkedIn
and push them out of L course okay I you
make content to take them out into your
world you don't want to be at the mercy
of a platform maybe I'll push you into
Twitter or something no no no your own
place my own your own place you got to
figure out where that going to be at
correct whether that's email whether
that's on a phone call whether that's
live streams you understand guess email
yeah it's not closed group on Facebook
but like don't rely on a platform take
them out just take them out take them
out appreciate it take care stay
well what's going on I was uh I was hit
by a car riding my bike [__] I was uh
training for an Iron Man yeah you look
in Crazy shape I was like thinking it
was going to be some weird [__] like
that can you sign a dedication page of
course you mind do it just sign it Adam
that' be great yeah but um were you
scared fuckless or it was like so St and
you didn't know what the [__] was going
on I didn't see what it even happened
and then next thing knew fli over my
handle bars packed my head on the
pavement ambulance hospital and knee I
had to get surgery on Min surg how how's
how do you feel mentally uh I was out of
work for 3 months which which absolutely
sucked do you uh do are are you at the
part yet that you see that the adversity
was a gift or you abely you do yeah and
I didn't see that for a while probably 2
months and then by the end of the third
month I just flipped the switch Yeah and
it made me I mean I'm just you always
talk about empathy and like that's like
even that dude your whole perspective
changed yeah absolutely anyways at this
young of an age it's such a gift yeah
I'm 23 and it such a gift what could
have been a I mean what almost a
near-death experience course it should
completely frame up the rest of your
life yeah and it's it's done a lot for
me and I didn't I wish I didn't had to
get hit by a car to realize that but who
gives the [__] how would happen it's
better you get hit by a car than you had
every family member die in a [__]
plane crash I'm serious hit by a car is
[__] [__] I mean it yeah people
have way worse [__] Happ absolutely it's
awesome and it could have been I me
obviously I don't want you to be banged
up exactly yeah and now I'm I always
think like I wish I had almost the
harder life to bring on some of the
lessons that I learned just in the last
five monity is the [__] Foundation
yeah it's awesome an eye opening
experience that's awesome bro thank you
I wish you well thank you very
much I'm in Philly love it thanks for
making the Dr a lot thank you very much
have a great holiday yeah hope you get
better thank you
app pretty crazy Place how are you
[__] doing man I'm doing super well
how are you great man I just wanted to
[__] come and say thank you for
[__] being awesome you know what I
mean like been watching your videos for
the last couple of weeks and like got
text new text me actually a week ago or
something I'm like I got meet this dude
and he's got so you just been you've
been consuming just recently yeah how
you how' you stumble on uh just YouTube
you came up and a bunch of other
motivation things I need a little kick
in the ass here and there and you dude
you know it better than everybody else
so thank you so much where do you live
uh South Wall so that's by madis balar
Ruckers grad so it's by the area yeah
pleasure
twoes nice to meet you bro have the best
holiday take
care right there thank you I'm Julia so
miss to meet you so nice to meet you of
course I can I'm shaking nice to meet
you yeah so um I've really been
following you for a little while exended
that on to you on YouTube and I qu my
job a month ago to start my own company
it's called Parenting by Design it's
exactly what you're saying like don't
let the parents just spr their kids so
they can you know grow and be as
confident as you are and change the
world so it's amazing so nice to meet
you happy holidays thank you and one two
five thank you take care of yourself
happy
holidays came back no worries no I just
wanted to get this time
got thank you appreciate it also do you
mind taking a video just like saying hey
this is Gary K Bryan
um what's good everybody Gary ve here my
man Brian you look handsome bro in this
video keep pushing empathy kindness all
of it always wins but patience all you
[__] aren't patient
enough thank you man I give you mys card
for please please thank you bro I'll
make sure I don't L it have a great
holiday how you doing sir I'm doing
super well how are you I'm doing well my
name is Shamar uh me and my wife own c
as right now congratulations but I want
to do a little bit more I want to get
into the real estate aspect of things
and have heart because I find that as a
way that I can utilize retail spaces to
get another dayare Center and also be
able to continue to build on and get
multip family homes okay my issue is
figuring out how to get the right heart
L they in all the above I never how the
what the right heartlander heartlander
yeah to get involved so I can actually
get the capital I need to make to happen
sooner than
later you know the answer is asking
right just asking dude it's literally
knocking on doors whether it comes from
a billionaire or a hedge fund or a
family office or a bank or somebody
random it's a single game of that if
you're asking for money you got to ask
just ask you know what I mean okay it's
hard I've never asked I'm not I'm not
good at asking for money either believe
it or not um but uh that is the answer s
good you know how it is million people
are going to say no right people going
to profile you people are going to not
profile people just don't like the idea
all you need is one person to say
Yes sounds good awesome thank you yeah
got you bro have a best holiday all
right 1 two
5 I may just get one of these yeah which
one I'll go with the Ros then cuz it's
fire thank you bro pleasure take care
have the best
holiday what's up bro nice to meet you H
good I wait what's your name Carson
Jones Carson hi um uh I have a question
so if you were want looking to start a
business at a young age yes how would
you um what are some strategies that you
would use to reach other people like um
get your opinions out and like sort of
um get the attention of other people
what do you need them for um buying your
thing got it so how do you Market the
customers yeah okay good what are you
selling well I don't know yet but um
well you need to know what you're
selling to know what you're going to do
to get attention because you can imagine
if you're send if you're selling
something that targets 15y old girls
well then Tik tok's going to matter
right if you're targeting your dad's CFO
then linkedin's going to matter so for
me to answer the question I have to know
the product and then I know the strategy
of how to get attention Okay make sense
yeah all right I think one of the things
that you should think about is whichever
platforms you're most comfortable with
are probably most likely a good idea to
try to sell a product to that audience
cuz you're more native to Tik Tok or
Instagram than you are to LinkedIn makes
sense right yeah awesome all right can I
grab a you can nice to meet you bro nice
to meet you to how are you selfie too
I'm a huge fan man thank you
bro two awesome wait
wait one two
and where do you live I live in summit
summit right here over I love it how you
doing man really good bro all right one
two five beautiful that's awesome have
the best Thanksgiving you too man thank
you so
much how are nice my name is Amanda my
gosh I have been watching your content
at least since the summer I changed jobs
and I finally went you know I want to be
on the front face we're nonprofit so I
wanted to start working with the donors
good for and I just I love the message
and it just keep
driving love it so P where do you live I
live in wh so not far not far all right
one two five Brandon
have the best holiday thank you and you
as well this is awesome thanks for
taking the time how we doing crushing
we're doing well ping ahead believe it
or not wild even in the store which is
mind is this a we're midway between an
hour so we're pacing just slightly ahead
but thank
BS 210 cases
already nice to meet you big man thank
you bro I'm in um credit restoration you
have any advice or you know anything
about credit I do what are you trying to
accomplish just uh building up a company
to get more customers yes LinkedIn
LinkedIn LinkedIn yeah content though
information not sales pitches okay
content that's where it is all right
bro
right thank you a lot have the best best
best best Thanksgiving what's good bro
great to see you how you been good man
you want me to sign that yes got you you
ever heard me recommend it or you just
grabbed it random somebody why I got got
a podcast right I'm going to start doing
and it's about notice and action okay
um when can I have you in the podcast
you know I don't want to [__] you
here but I think if you put out a good
so here's what you should do you should
take the photo from this you should
email to me when you get to 50 episodes
you send me an email thank you have the
best
holiday two
5 take care of
yourself what's up Gary what's good bro
what's good bro nice to meet you
pleasure thank you my name is Noel Noel
yeah man no
o and my question is this I have a Fed
Restoration company that I opened up in
June 1st 2018 it's blown up when no no I
still don't have my full website work
it's or referrals I took what I know
from business and PA high commissions I
got you operations I'm [__] lost you
need to hire
somebody that's what it is 100 and and
another thing that I like is putting my
content like I don't know it's like I
feel like I'm not that good at putting
content that's why you
[Music]
lost
got see he [__] me up
already you understand yes when you've
already decided you lost you actually
did okay stop woring about what people
say stop worrying about Dustin seeing
that you have a post with one like on it
who gives a [__] I had one like too go
look at my tweets from 2007 I got two
[__] likes two thank you
understand D if you edit that show one
from 07 with two likes up Hi how are you
doing good how are you happy holidays
than you a hug of course apprciate I'm
all about a hug I want to say thank you
for you know all the positivity that you
do put out it's helpful on a daily basis
it really is you're very sweet thank you
for saying that a few of the things that
you've mentioned or at least that have
stuck out to me recently have been
LinkedIn obviously brand and podcast I
love that so LinkedIn going all in on as
as possible everying have you already
started doing it oh yeah you seeing
anything oh yeah that's awesome
everything's like dou it's great it's
great so um I would have done that
anyway but thank you you're welcome and
uh so bran we're working on that too do
custom apparel and we're trying to
figure out where that Niche might be um
what's the you do custom apparel yeah I
think Tik Tok you have to look at
heavily I know we're working on that
please that's where the action is my
friends too trying to get where do you
live um over in Dum
[Music]
awesome
awesome you will one two
go ahead you um so the third thing would
be podcasts and so what I'm trying to do
is get people together so that I can do
a podcast on um building brand and where
people are at with what they're doing
intentionally and What stages that
they're doing that at and where I'm at
is two years of business so early stages
conversational podcast smart yeah so
trying to bring people in so that they
have a platform for I got yous a lot of
that are just trying to get started on
the ground and when they're trying to
bring in just make would you be my fifth
interview fifth oh I like where you went
with that when when would that be
February okay you send me an email with
that photo and put fifth interview
February 4th I'll give you the answer
50/50 I don't want to [__] you but
I'll try more more lo 5050 on five but
if not then 55 is real all right take
care have a great
holiday hi nice to meet you nice to meet
you um really quick so you've been kind
of pitching like leakedin for a while
now so my question is how often should
we have it like updated now I'm posting
25 times a day 25 a day a day a day okay
all right the answer is as much as you
can okay and do you think that as in
terms of like getting like more jobs or
just like everything it'll just lead to
more opportunities everything but you
have to put out content not sales
pitches right okay something that brings
value mhm okay and second question what
is your favorite Portugese wine and if
you have any you know what's funny I
love I'm obsessed with Portuguese buying
there's a bunch Jim Gorman downstairs
does the Portuguese buying you have to
find him he will give you a much better
recommendation me I'm a little rusty all
right thank you so much appreciate Ito
one two five Jim Gorman got it awesome
take Happy Thanksgiving
bye thank you man yeah nice to meet you
get you the sign somebody recommended
this to you didn't they no so this is a
beast of a wine so I was in line I was
like I got to give them to sign
something I just grabbed that dude this
is a beast of a wine so my name is Paul
Paul yeah how are you doing bro good man
so uh this might not be the right time
but might be my only opportunity I'm
launching a business that's going to
completely disrupt the Home Services
industry no one's out there doing it
right now I know the key to the success
is going to be like a social media
social marketing platform I don't have
any of that I don't know if it's
something you ever look at as far as
maybe partnering with somebody it's less
likely partnering but I might because I
just I'm not in that mindset these days
but I can definitely help you find
people that may uh just email me at Gary
ofner media it's in literally in this
book if you forget plus you should talk
to James or my CEO at uh the president
of the Sasha Group which does the SMD
stuff that we do there might be some
ways we can help yeah I just think
somebody you know would be great cuz cuz
whether it was my mom raising three kids
on her own busting her ass it's all
about brain transparency looking out for
the customer couldn't more in this
industry we're doing it with Vayner
Sports every industry whoever is the
most transparent and brings the most
value will always win and there's no one
doing it in our industry right now I
love it and so we want to we're we are
the first and we will be the first but I
know that we got to launch right we got
to do it the right way so I know what to
do um what's his name his name is James
orini James or how can I
do beautiful beautiful take care brother
you want to
email hi it's so good to meet you nice
to meet you um I'm working on this
project and I would love to send you a
copy when I'm done I kind of see things
very black and white you're either
focused on your goals or your excuses
and so I'm making click books out of
them um this is not going to be the
final form I see where you're going but
I think you might I'm changing the font
so that's not it but I think I think you
think it's really I think it's really
neat I I agree with you on the
perspective so how can I get through a
copy like when I'm done
just no I'll give you my email my email
is Gary at bner media okay that's when
you when you email me and say we're
going to take this photo video you'll
email say it's done I'll reply with an
address and who to send it to and this
way I'll get it okay that's great
awesome thank you very much appreciate
it thank you thank
you thank you thank you so much happy
holidays hey I just want to thank you so
much um you motivated me so much I go
through a lot of depression and anxiety
like that and every time I look you know
every morning a blessing you're very
sweet what's your name Charlene Charlene
thank you so much all right one two five
yeah your
phone Charlene make sure the picture is
good cuz he said it was a little blurry
let me see actually you know
what yeah sorry don't worry I know let
me see if I can see if I can find
it all right bet Take Care thank you
man theth the myth the legend how are
you bro just want to say thank you you
know I live in sprink New Jersey
actually you're on the pillars so one of
my business successes right now my you
been St before uh I'm a picture wine
text they know me by name downstairs
love it thank you bro I just want to say
thank you for you bro thank you so much
two I wish you well bro happy holidays
thank you and your
family what's up fam I'm up man how are
you I'm great man what's your name man
my name j c man you you changed my life
man thank you like yeah I was homeless
for like 2 years man while I was
homeless living in North man I wasn't in
the books none of that they it's God put
me on some books and you was like crush
crush it was like one of the first books
that I read man and now yeah exactly it
hit the switch man you know and now I'm
I'm working on being a social media
teacher go and stuff like that you
know proud of you bro real happy
holidays all you too man all 1 two 5
beautiful take the best holiday so nice
to meet you I wish you nothing but the
best man how's it going real well how
are you good question for you man so
just uh recently a couple months ago I
was in Dubai yes and like I get around
like traveling a lot you know and I'm
going to guitar in a couple of weeks so
just any advice travel and stuff like
that like how to get more exposure like
to do a certain topic you know traveling
like yeah yeah what would you like to
happen to be able to afford to do it
exposure yeah more content more content
keep traveling as much as I can more
content more content will lead to that
one post that gets some travel company
to see you to pay for you to do more
it's
content ER you know what's that Eric
con travel guy in New York it's
awesome whether it's Eric or me or
somebody else that answers more content
agency it it could no it could be an
airline a travel agency uh the Council
of a place like in Chile there's a
million different ways it could happen
okay all right
man yeah hope you have the best holiday
all right man
ready one
two man he seeing JFK I hope so
bro I see it
to see you brother how are you again
great to see you I got your email I'll
bang on it this weekend I already I
talked to Harvey from Equinox today oh
my God that's perfect I've got you fully
emotion I will take I will fully take
care of this man I appreciate it you
look great brother great to see you it
was really fun meeting with you did you
tell them how good of the meeting was it
was awesome thank you again it's emotion
yes how you
Thanksgiving what
I no no you do man good me see you bro
good ni see you your inspiration man
thank you bro like literally 45 hour ago
early today I actually found out about
this like about an hour ago got some
stuff going on like hard almost about to
for close on my house but I still got
here cuz I was like I got to do it and I
got hit by a car last year and I was
watching your videos while was held up
for 9 months so I really really
appreciate it man thank you bro really
appreciate you can you uh just sign
yeah you know really really motivate me
I didn't even I'm still here sitting
here with a smile in my face with all
this stuff that's what keep going on bro
a house means nothing yeah if you're
[__] happy here [__] a house on real
[__] no I feel you not really I need
those words it's true cuz it's true
forget about Judgment of others that you
ain't got to [__] all that all you need
is something like you don't need [__]
you just need be happy just be in my car
right that's truth bro that's truth if
you got the right perspective on it if
you're like one step backwards three
steps forward yeah that's all it is
crazy thing is I'm trying to do young
yeah 30 you're [__] baby okay
appreciate that that's sound some real
[__] probably look just as old as you n
man you look
great and one two five beautiful have
the best holiday bro put in perspective
I'm really glad you game I say there man
just like but I got to see car is better
than
zero it's true you
know you doing man really well how are
you good good um I don't have any
questions I just want to say
yep thank um I've been following you for
over seven years now and um I watch your
content every day I'm in door to door
sales I've been doing it for 3 years now
it's a It's a Grind it's aw a gr it is
um I just want to say thank you I don't
have any crazy you say this you know I
get it I get it by now post you know
keep us and keep work because because
the one game that Trump's not out
hustling somebody door to door is for
them to come to you no matter what you
sell wait say that one more time the
content thing is so important for door
to door sales because no matter what you
sell branding non transactional of
course cuz if they they reach out to you
instead of you to them you know what it
is right now s 40 to9 I put solar up on
but I'm trying to do something where I
can brand myself not sell for somebody
else be in the video just brand myself
make the video tell them the value of
solar over
not hey real quick a Instagram
video
my I guess I don't know some words of
for followers y
f
yo this Thanksgiving remember one thing
kindness never
lost thank you so much apprciate save it
I didn't save it take care stay well how
are you hey Pete man nice to meet you
such a pleasure yeah no want me to sign
yeah if you could please uh just a
jersey guy in uh in technology Wireless
Telecom yep uh but no just motivated by
things that you put out there uh I live
in we hawk and grew up in uh Mammoth
County Township I know well but uh no I
mean it's good to have Jersey guys out
there pushing things I agree so I'm
pushing it on some of my Canadian
employees you know whether they like it
or not a little too Jersey for that no
they well I'm the boss so they have to
learn to live with it but uh definitely
appreciate everything thank you for
stopping by yeah absolutely one two five
hope you have the best holiday yeah you
too very nice Mee thank you
thanks what's up bro it's good to see
what's up man how you been pretty good
man I'm mind's brother I know exactly
where I've seen it yeah what
up me it's been good how can I help my
brother like kind of like he's he's
happy he's fulfilled and I'm his older
brother I just want him to be happy take
it to the next level you probably been
monitoring far away I have you need to
make sure that that's based on what he
wants not what you want for him that's
the number one game bro it's a very like
I don't want to mess with it either
doing really well bro I've got it the
same thing with my brother true that
Dynamic you will lose if it's you
imposing what you want for them versus
you listening to them what they want for
themselves you understand it's against
our
instincts but it is the answer that's
true death family Dynamic where do you
live I'm in Jersey I'm in Paran now I
grew up in Bluefield I just [__] with
everything Jersey man me too BR went to
ruers everything like Jersey everything
I'm here locally so glad to meet you
person real pleasure yeah real pleasure
Qui picture yeah of course re hooking it
up it's always good to see
[Music]
re hope you great
Thanksgiving man you I like the white on
black combo you really nailed it today
to hi I just like saying hi to you I
love seeing you too see real well um I
don't want to take too much of your time
I'm main thing I actually have a reason
to come here um I'm working with an
influencer now I'm technically his
business manager it's ridiculous um you
actually might know so he's friends with
A-Rod Stevie Macky he's coached all
these people okay um I don't know go
ahead okay so he's just he's a vocal
coach like celebrity vocal coach trying
to blow him up he's already big but um
extremely talented he just launched a
master class today and I want to get it
some attention any chance enrollment
closes like mid December or late
December CH we can get you guys to do
something together yes but it but you
know how you know how I am I would never
push a course so I have to figure out
how to thread the it's more of like he
has a book and it's like hey he also
just launched his book today no um no no
no I for you the answer is oh I'm always
trying to figure out how for it to be
yes mainly I I also just want to get you
guys together that's
fine hey I also have this I'm I'm
thrilled to figure it out I don't want
you to push anything I won't to your
point I will definitely have him come in
for 15 minutes and we'll Yap and we'll
make content we'll be able to awar this
cool uh who do I should just reach out
to taiway me me me I'll I'll pass it on
to the admin team cool also can it be in
January cuz my December 22nd I think
okay so we'll have to it's going to be a
late night or like we'll thread the
needle I'll figure out 15 cool all right
um he's in La so if you're ever I don't
know if you're going to be there I I
might once I don't know I'll let you
know okay cool and also I remember in
feu January when we talked he said the
one thing he wanted was relationships
can you give me like one name that
you're trying to meet that I can you
know what's funny I can get everybody
I'd rather that would put you in a [__]
spot what I'd rather have is you to feel
comfortable to email me when you're
building relationships organically and
be like yo this person because I can get
to everybody I can literally DM anybody
I want that's not you know what I mean
that's why I'm like what do you what can
I help you with I'm just like it's not
about that it's about it's about when
there's true organic nature to it than
executing on that okay see what I mean
like this is organic exactly that's why
I said yes to that that's not one name I
was going to come up with you understand
he's cool he he didn't even know who you
were I believe it like aod talks about
you all the time I he always with him
it's done I will find 15 I'll see you
soon I'll see you next couple weeks have
a great great Thanksgiving great to see
you Russ coming out soon I'm aware I
spoke to Russ about it the other day I
can't wait to hear it all right stay
well hello hello um what's your name AJ
AJ one of my favorite
names is that how are you us at the show
this summer oh no kidding oh holy cow
with with Xander right there yes dude oh
my God it's great to see you guys see
you guys so great how have you been uh
good so um I have an ebay account over
like two months now I made like $800
about it's amazing um that's awesome
selling stuff around the house yeah yeah
um but I was kind of wondering what uh
like what else I could sell and invest
in cuz a lot of stuff on eBay it's hard
to flip and yep the key the key with
eBay is to your point you could like
look up something and this sells for 15
but if there's not enough demand it
doesn't flip the reason I got good at
eBay when I was a kid and even before
there was an eBay when I was your age
just is because I listened more than I
tried to sell so one of the things that
is really smart to do on eBay is when
you're living your life like kids in
school talking about something blade run
you know cards sneakers whatever is to
always look up stuff on eBay and then go
to completed items and really get a
sense of how much popularity there is or
isn't there's not a lot of popularity
don't buy it that's right you you
realize wait a minute there isn't as
much demand the other thing I would say
is I couldn't push you more to think
about garage sales garage sales yeah
it's loaded yeah like how do you find
them cuz I I look for them Google all
right where do you live Mountain Lakes
like uh maybe near Bo yep you first of
all there's apps garage sail and other
things but if you Google your town and
garage sale inevitably you're going to
get a listings of five or six that are
that weekend and then you run up to Dad
and be like Dad I got to go cool cuz you
can't drive yet yeah yeah I don't know
if it'll let you take an Uber so I doubt
it so then you got to yell at him all
right all right mhm thank you it's so
good to see you all right are you guys
going to be Atlantic City yeah can't we
are that's
awesome all five
days I'm going for the whole time so
good to see have you ever been to this
story before pretty cool right I got to
do all my this is not a joke you need to
email me at Gary of Vayner
media there's a 30% there's a 50% chance
in January February that I'm going to do
a card show on on this floor we set up
or just you you're going to set up oh
really yeah that's why I'm bringing it
up to you so that you set up I'll set up
you read the post at all newor post yeah
yeah we got a big ad in there tomorrow
on Friday it's my ad good for you it's
so good to see you again great to see
you again all right we'll see you soon I
will take care
guys I've been a fan for so thank you
for that Christine from New
Jersey
got the good ones the dark clouds it's a
hard one to get yeah I've had them for
this for so longk be a blogger YouTuber
it's so good to see
you all right one
two where do you guys live West half
hour oh super close close thanks for
coming yeah I saw you posted it
yesterday and I said to her I'm like
Gary's going to be in Springfield I
wasn't even really sure how close it was
yeah we're like that's only half hour
away let's go I'm glad so it's the first
time at the store yeah crazy huh nice
it's really nice other thing I just
wanted you to know so this book helped
me when I had a YouTube channel and I
had 11,000 subscribers but then I had to
choose between being a teacher and doing
the YouTube thing so I went back to
being a teer are you enjoying it I am
and I'm out and then I go back to doing
this we things since what oh my gosh
years I love it our eBay account we love
I can't wait to do them again can't wait
for the spring this year I got a 1980s
uh Transformer set 10 bucks I sold it
for 145 but but you started doing the
stuffed animals I'm like Dustin you
better do some stuffed animals he like
literally like two days later I went in
and there was some old Muppets um
stuffed animals sold them for like 25
bucks each stuffed animals are
surprising I know
awesome nice to meet Take Care thank you
guys
Hi how are you I'm Justin from B Hi how
are you good good how's it going good
what's Babble box um it's my mom's
company and is it a good company yeah
does your mom work hard yeah do you help
it mhm what do you do I make the Box
you're amazing how old are you eight
that's so awesome today my birthday
happy birthday brother you were seven
yesterday yeah and now you're eight and
are you pumped
are you excited awesome hi hi I'm Sher I
just want to say thank you I mean
everything that you do my parents are
immigrants and I'm a first generation so
everything that you do just resonates
and every time you say something it's
like something that like kindness like I
was just writing an article on kindness
and it's just really amazing that same
waving yeah so and I've spoken to people
from your company like we did I think an
Oreo campaign yeah so just want to say
thank you happy holidays thank you you
too such a pleasure thanks for coming
thank you photo oh the dog's here
too now I got to go cook
again thank you
guys who brought how are thank you guys
who brought the family to America I said
aren't you glad you came to America I
brought the family I just said I told
when when I was
three
I to I would love a bottle thank you
Gary you're welcome I'm sorry we're not
going to take any
I just want to say thank you man
emotional thank you
bro thank you so
much where you from
B yeah B New Jersey yes you just changed
my home perspective man I quit my
[__] job happy just looked at life
different but you know what it
is the way you value him yeah
real [__] I'm going [__] DM you cuz I
can't even say it but good bro thank I'm
over here take this photo FaceTime a
girl for you she [__] loves you bro
thank you
two I quit my job start selling on
Amazon everything it's not enough money
man but take my dad to the doctor's
appointment
proud what's her name I'm
face
she's fuing happy too I definitely want
her to meet you of
course [__] K
me she's [__] come on
an she has to be
trolling what's good why are you not
here I'm very
upset your hair is good stop no she had
to get her hair done it looks good it
looks good Ang your hair looks
phenomenal it's fresh you look [__]
amazing hey happy
holidays thank you you too I hope you
have the best
Thanksgiving thank you I
will good got you bro stay well
apprciate have a good one I saved some
screenshots I know thank you man long
really popular good how you doing nice
to meet you I'm Ari I want to come say
hello first of all I like to P wine s
obviously that's really really it's an
awesome project I love it I'm so psyched
about it you should email Brandon atwin
library.com I'm sure like to know about
it yeah because we were right there oh
yeah yeah we like we're always looking
for new projects and we do awesome stuff
and the only thing is I'm not like the
marketing like I'm awesome at the wine
like I can crush it with the wine I have
like my wst I'm working through the
diploma everything it's like but I don't
know how to do like the marketing I like
you should go say hi to Gary go ask me
about the marketing angle I was like
it's about content it's about you making
videos and talking about what you know
the end it's not marketing it's putting
out information that you know yeah yes
it's like that's that's it that's it and
you think it's more worth it to like to
somebody who like does the marketing or
just like try and do it yourself try at
first to do it yourself yeah absolutely
cool man thanks 1 2 5 literally make
videos and talk about kosha wi yeah and
crush it it's awesome thanks who am I
going those two Sasha and Brandon thank
you so much let's meet you take care
let's good bro what's going on how are
you Jo I'm good Joe nice to meet you
Jimmy Jimmy what's up bro all your
Instagram stuff makes me hustle every
day thank you wake up in the morning I
stay up all night thank you oh my God
where do you live I live in North Jersey
so I was like an hour uh Sussex yeah I
know it well really my cousin lived
there really yeah I know well yeah two
five beautiful and uh I have a question
real quick and then you keep talk one
two so I like I'm a videographer so like
I I do I do like weddings and stuff but
like I want to do music videos and stuff
when I get older but like the reason I
want to go to college for is like I know
I have the skill but I want to do it for
the connections in like the city cuz
like I don't really know anybody is not
going to be the way just DM 500 rappers
bro you could DM the baby and he might
say
yes [__] that that's completely the
wrong [__] answer literally go sit
down right now in bed open up [__]
Instagram and DM the Thousand [__]
freshest artists in the world and say I
will make I will do video for you for
free that's what drock did really dck
didn't go to [__] college to get to
me [__] emailed me and was like I'll
make free [__] for you I'm like okay
like right now if you do that for Russ
the baby GNA somebody's going to say yes
MH I Wai to get this in real life I just
been watching all time I wish you well
bro do what I just said don't [__]
pay for a [__] piece of paper that's
not going to get you the connections you
want either you're good or
not get a quick selfie you understand
that part though yeah like don't hide
behind School stuck with don't hide
behind school either you're good or not
mhm
yeah what's up oh wait hold I was that
was
great we got it you're the man bro thank
you have a great holiday okay no worry
I'm good you're welcome bro I hope you
have a great Thanksgiving stay
well nice for meeting you man so nice to
meet you my name is Alejandro Alejandra
nice to meet you I'm from Ecuador you're
such an inspiration thank you sir thank
you I appreciate you so much uh your
podcast your videos inspired me just to
start my company and and really uh do
what I love that is promote um small
communities from my country I love it
good for you thank you so much I have a
couple of questions from your three
questions that I did he favorite color
favorite cartoon favorite number
favorite color green favorite number
five favorite cartoon a little tricky
but I'd probably say ultimately there's
a very rare small cartoon called laugh
Olympics it was from the 770s laugh
Olympics it's my favorite cartoon thank
you so much Portugal which wine red wine
find Jim Gorman Jim I'm a little bit
Rusty Portugal I haven't tasted a bunch
in a while but Jim buys Portugal for us
here he's downstairs Jim Gorman as for
Jim pce of advice if I get frustrated
one two five the frustration is simple
it's you know the reality on that
is when it comes to frustration like in
two years if I get frustrated what would
you tell me if you what's the [__]
alternative that's the answer like okay
hey now 2 years from now you here what's
the alternative so what you're
frustrated get over and move on thank
you Gary very insiration thank you thank
you my friend Jim
Jim how are you my man good real
pleasure my name is Frank I'm the guy we
spoke before I'm the guy that did the
work here when your last book signing on
the building remember that whole thing
of course I did bro it's great to see
you you too man thank you for that I
sold the [__] [__] out of you coming
to one of the jobs remember we were
going you were going to come
out we spoke on the phone I remember all
and what we what happened we lost my
admin [__] let's get right back on I had
no idea my admins rule my life of course
I remember I remember that conversation
like yesterday as you can tell yeah I
can't let's do it I sold the [__]
[__] out so what do I have to do going
to come by where which one uh let me
think about it CU I'm starting a new
company now so this could be the biggest
springboard ever for me it's done dude
you already did the part it's my turn to
fulfill you just got to put me
what little Lou Lou what's your email s
r i c c h i h i o l a striola
Gmail is that right yep I need to go to
Frank's job in 20120 Lou call
him he'll
explain call him he will explain we
spoke to Tyler right speak to Tyler will
know
but
just just as he did something for Dad
and I have to show up in my Vlog at a
job he has in New
Jersey in
2020 I'm so glad you came bro I'm so
sorry there was a hiccup on that I'm
ready to go I remember that it was
[__] up a little bit like it was
getting tougher and you were thinking
about it different company I'm ready so
dude here starting the new dude you you
get on the phone with Lou will get
locked in and and it will be done no
problem bro Gary can I steal this cool
thank you so much thank you I was I was
nervous when I came back no worries bro
pleasure thank you so much homie mean it
have the best holiday I can't wait to do
it I will [__] blast it I will
[__] blast it I really appreciate
what you did here I will [__] blast
it we just got just my intent is to do
it I didn't realize there was a lapse I
literally I don't think about it every
[__] day but I thought we were
waiting to the other thing so I wouldn't
have known so just know it's a wrap it's
100% good bro stay well 17 years old you
changed my [__] life thank you br
like no [__] bro but like you know I'm
98 out of 100 I'm not giving a [__] upst
I get it that's a great number already
because of your content yes like you
know and at 17 it's hard to be 100 and
you're 64 in a day literally I I post 50
to 70 times a day now
and what are you seeing what and what
are you seeing like I'm see I'm seeing
great results you know I have 20,000
followers on Tik Tok you know I just
post videos of me like you
knowes and like that people love this
[__] like I posted one video that got
like 700,000 views ridiculous right uh
but I want to ask you a question right
so uh I I haven't heard you talk about
uh Shopify Drop Shipping yeah yeah so uh
what I want to ask you is basically U I
believe in it so what I want to ask you
um I'm going don't worry no don't worry
I'm not going anywhere I'm right here I
don't talk let me let me tell you why I
don't talk about Drop Shipping and then
maybe you'll remember I don't talk about
Drop Shipping a lot because I don't do
it and I like talking about [__] I know
oh yeah I'm aware about Drop Shipping a
lot of the homies that flip or follow me
do a ton of Drop Shipping I'm super
close to Shopify I understand the
infrastructure I'm totally about it yeah
go ahead so if you were 17 years old
what would and you just found out about
droping what would be your strategy and
what what would you sell right now I
would probably pay attention to Tik Tok
and Instagram all day and figure out
what dumb [__] everyone's hot on so like
when the visco girl started popping 4
months ago I probably would have done a
water bottle if it was 2 years ago when
it was the solar eclipse I would have
bought those [__] glasses I would
like ride a wave are you seeing any one
products right now no cuz I haven't done
the homework yeah I got you yeah all
right that's all I know or the complete
opposite and I would sell something that
I'm really about yeah like hoodies a
beanie I would probably do a beanie cuz
I [__] with beanies you know like that
kind of [__]
yeah would you make a Tik Tok with me
right now yeah really yeah all right
awesome just say something this is
awesome
ready guys I can't believe this moment
right now I'm here with Gary V give him
some positivity Tik Tok I'm going to
give you the greatest [__] secret of
all time don't listen to anybody not a
teacher not a parent listen to
yourself you heard
it thank you stay well bro thank you so
much for putting happy to do it look
good how are you good man real well
what's up bro hey man good to see you
have you been fantastic just talking
with Sasha for a minute you got to talk
to him about it a little bit Yeah bit
Yeah I have your email I'm just I'm
actually literally going to talk to him
about it this weekend cool I got to sa
my inbox there's a bit of a gap I think
on what he's saying as far as the market
but I think he'll tune into a lot more
relative to folks like DK Morgan stuff
like that where I think you know he's
seeing a disconnect on both the
immediate market and long-term Market of
things that I'm talking about he's also
conservative by Nature totally
understood he's from my dad's generation
like the same age so I totally get like
that generation being risk averse and
stuff like that I'll speak to I have
your email right at the top of my inbox
it's my to-do list for tomorrow awesome
appreciate that I had some random [__]
for you so this first of all is
something that we'll probably be
appreciated now I know you're big on the
brother this this is amazing both from
stat I know this whole thing bro they
were both from stat I actually picked
that up like from a friend of family
that's [__] amazing and then just for
like random Insanity to show you hang on
one sec so this is from me back in the
day and I think you'll appreciate this
so one
sec legit you know who that is that's
one of my number five Jersey from so
good so good bro so good so good
awesome bro and then I have this for you
this is basically like so basically a
couple different shots one one at Scout
for something like that and one with
label one with your label love it super
cool you want me to what are you doing
with this awesome I'll try them out
tomorrow make give those to dad cuz I'm
going to take them the house I just gave
him one of each he's got one of each
otherwise thank you so much for toar
let's be this weekend all right all
right brother appreciate you so Gary
when I we did this video okay I told you
I was going to write my book and get it
published I wanted to give you an
autograph copy a year and a half man
because I know you've always said no one
has really come back to you I love it
brother and said hey I'm going to do
what I'm going to do yeah man so you
inspired me and then I told you too in
that video that I was going to write a
children's book I got an agent so that's
my side hustle and the whole way through
man so that book is doing really well we
sold out on Amazon is there any way
you'd be able to do like a quick like
just hold book and say I got you I know
what
you I got you don't worry bro thank
you so look a lot of people say it and
don't do it this handsome man said it
and did it go do yours magic of Mayfair
Gary ve thanks bro hopefully you you
watch or you read it you like it that's
unlikely that's what that's what that's
what I don't [__] but I'm proud F yeah
man I appreciate it thanks for
motivating me a year and a half Journey
just to at least come to you and say I
did it I'm proud of you have a great
Thanksgiving hi great like I having a
shitty day at work I just put you on my
podcast and like YouTube and I listen to
you like I'll repeat and it's just like
it just makes my day better so I just
wanted to come here are hi it's my
husband jaani hey how are you so nice to
meet you happy
holidays yeah I mean there's so much
going on like ideas all that stuff and
so like I really got to go into action
but I'm like it's all action and like
I'm trusting the process and all that
stuff you got plenty of time but you do
have to put an
and you have to figure out how much of
your non-action is based on insecurity
you have to figure that out PR much you
know if you're worried about judgment
outside of you too if you're worried
about judgment you'll never do yeah you
have to figure that out and it might not
be that you just might be the kind of
person that likes to do what's in front
of you right but if it is about judgment
you have to break that cycle okay yeah
I'm sure so it's just making it happen
so the question is who's judgment yeah
that's what you have to play with cuz
that's I believe the reason I do so much
is I don't care about what people think
when I fail and I think most people
struggle with that yeah that's true yeah
and once you get over that once you're
not worried about your mom's opinion
your husband's opinion your best
friend's opinion somebody at work's
opinion once you get over that then you
start doing and then the whole game
changes yeah and thank you for also
including people who are not Millennials
cuz I know I feel like you're always
talking to Millennials I'm always
talking to Millennials because I do so
much Instagram content but but I'm
trying to do more of not because yeah
I'm not I know I just heard like found
out about you years ago on
Fest that's where I just
like but all
right
um all
right it yeah thank you inspiration
thank you my friend I have a where do
you guys live uh West awesome have you
been here before yeah we've awesome
thank you take
care hey bro hey bro how are you nice to
meet you excited to to meeting you nice
to meet you uh my name is Adan I'm from
Ecuador very nice yeah I'm just in the
city visiting my family to live here I'm
so glad we got to meet they they've been
living here like 30 years and we've been
separated 15 years because migration and
stuff yes I know SS so me and my brother
we have this over company running
between Ecuador and the US and I'm
really pumped because of your content so
I just want to say thank you because of
your efforts and all the content you're
putting away I'm really appreciated and
thank you for saying that no I really
mean it uh
and can I ask you a a little little
favor as being a Latin American
entrepreneur and right now there are so
difficult times over there so I I would
like to ask you you can deliver a quick
message to young entrepreneurs over
there so so they
can maybe they can avoid all all the
noise there my friends my brothers and
sisters in latam listen to me don't
don't let the noise on the outside mess
you up it's very simple no matter how
many struggles no matter what's going on
with global immigration the economy
other noises the presidents it doesn't
matter you're fully in control you're
fully it's it's much better in Latin
America today than it was 40 years ago
you're lucky to be alive now with the
internet where we can meet like this
with free content get your head into a
positive place cuz the reality is with
the internet anything is possible and if
you want to believe the other side
that's fine but that's not going to
allow you to do anything so my friends
tune out the bad and pump in the good
nice thanks H little guy you're welcome
well
yeah
Pho
obvious awesome um my name is Alvar is
my brother uh I Liv here in the city in
in the country for what 12 years okay uh
with him as he mentioned we've been
starting the software company and we've
been trying to change from growing
organically you know we've been growing
organically for probably the past 2
years but now uh in in my case I've been
finding your content just recently and I
found it really inspirational thank you
um I was wondering what can you uh I
don't know share with us about I don't
know the gges of trying to grow using
marketing now in emerging economies like
in South America um I guess my question
is more about the gacha that we may find
I don't know if that actually makes
s what one more time what are you trying
to accomplish you looking for customers
in the US uh not really in the US but in
that region in South America Ecuador
well I mean you know when I look at
Ecuador's cost of price on Instagram and
YouTube and Facebook it's way better
than it is in America everything I say
works better in Ecuador than it does in
America cuz cuz the prices is
cheaper it's big fish in small
pond I could be the most famous person
in Ecuador in 6 months if I just ran ads
on and converted my content to Spanish I
would crush it
works do it yeah more more content much
more you understand much
more thank you all right take care guys
stay well you're welcome my friend thank
you oh my God I'm so nervous but I don't
care um what's your name Max name is Max
I know I've been a fan of you for so
long andk you just just this moment
right here like insane where do you live
uh North Arlington New Jersy all right
so I just got a quick little thing like
I've been working in construction since
I was 12 with my father we're immigrants
and came here I know the story all right
yeah so I quit just about 2 years ago I
turned 18 and I moved to my to Ecuador
okay for a year I did some business with
China I got [__] finessed I got Robb
I was it was young I didn't know what I
was do and you wanted it too fast pretty
much that's why kids get finessed young
kids get finessed cuz they want [__] too
fast yeah and so they think they're
doing something that's about I'mma put
two I'm going to get 10 real quick yeah
exactly I was going to get 10 but it
didn't happen it's [__] cliche bro in
said you put in two and it ghosted and
you got zero well yeah I had to go back
well it wasn't like I wasn't flipping
anything got I had to go back with my
family and I started working in
construction like with my father but I
hated it and I still do I quit and I
started full-time trading okay Bitcoin
leverage trading okay I had such good
like initiative like in the beginning I
was making more than I was making and
constructing okay then I had a big loss
cuz I was a newbie I was a new yeah you
got caught now
like so many things have built up my
father almost died not so long ago I was
in hospital and I had to leave
everything aside and I started to
realize that there's things that really
don't matter in life but like money yeah
yeah yeah like I was just looking at my
father and I was like [__] that right
you don't need to crush Bitcoin to buy a
Ferrari you just want your dad to be
okay exactly real life exactly so that's
good yeah so now like he's finally
feeling better he out of work he doesn't
work okay but we got hell medical bills
coming of and I literally have an
optimistic mind that the whole is going
toally and
[__] so now is this is my thing
should I leave the trading [__] and then
just go back into like construction do
you want to I don't so but you think
it'll be the right thing to do just
because my father is is what's up what's
going
on excuse me for a second yeah go to the
back and bring the car to the front
Okay but yeah and know I don't want to
do that to stick to but you think it's
the right thing to do for your family
here's the good news how old are you 20
if you did that for 5 years and
fulfilled that promise to your family
you'll be young as [__] when you're done
25 young as [__] I'd RI both my arms off
to be 25 I know you did that with your I
sure did I [__] built this [__]
building until I was 34 and left with
nothing literally nothing yeah so so do
that okay and guess what after a year
and a half of that that's not working
anymore then go trade and there's no
right answer just come with the right
intent all right pH 1 2
5 I wish you well bro thank you I love
you back bro take
care hey G how's it going how are you
what time is Rock uh [__] I don't really
have a question for you I just want to
thank you for all you do thank you uh I
actually do uh I did a hip-hop I don't
know if you remember but I did a uh I do
a hip-hop podcast I interviewed Tabby
wakes and I posted a little I made it
Jets like Jets colors and stuff just to
just so you would see it so um yeah I
just really appreciate everything you
do one two five beautiful all right
thank you take
care you it's good to see you how you
been yeah it's good to see you again
appr I like the M Monday playl thank you
bro I appreciate it how you been doing
good good want me to sign there
y
two I hope you have a great Thanksgiving
bro take care of
yourself wait oh wait hold on hold on I
got to do a lead up I was making a whole
Vlog though my guy how are you nice to
meet you man nice to meet you bro you
inspire me so much bro I'm extremely
grateful for all thank you you really
motivated me to go for film making which
is what I've been trying to do and it's
just I even have my own podcast and
stuff on my grind just it's very inspir
and I'm from uh sville New Jersey that
yeah so hearing that you're from New
Jersey I was telling my mom in the car I
was like took it to another level it
does connect home it's home yeah and I I
have my own parents that are like
they're from Colombia right so they came
here a good life and that work ethic so
anytime you say that I really connect
with that's awesome bro I'm so glad
you're here thank you photo yeah who's
got it D Rock one two
three you mind get in a Tik Tok revie
yeah let's do
[Music]
it so nice to meet
you get that to your
camera yeah get that to your
[Music]
camera got it you going to tell
everybody have to leave in 5
minutes I thought you the L you're I do
see the line I didn't know the time
though I saw the line I just didn't know
what time it was you could have helped
me with
that you you telling me there's a long
line brought me zero [__] value you
telling me what time it was would have
been nice D Rock All Right One this
Cameron is not that great yeah I know
right hold on ready one two
three
ready thank you thank you we got yeah we
got to get moving I'm going to do this
quick T to Let's Go
All TI
to all right starting the Tik Tok off
just chilling at the wine library and oh
[__] it's real it's my guy it's my guy
I'm his guy what's up bro I'm his
guy my guy
have a great holiday take care have a
great holiday byebye how's it going how
are you so nice to meet you thank you
I'm so so my uncle like probably 10 15
years ago is in the wine industry in New
Jersey what's his name his name is
Martin vanell I don't know if I ran 10
15 years ago and like now I told him
that I'm coming here to The Wine Library
and he's like oh my God like I can't
even believe it dude I I really
appreciate everything that you put out
um I just graduated from Penn State I
actually so I met Tyler she last year at
the sports business
you any interest 20th we would to
you don't TR for anything that's not
paying fees which I don't think guys
00,000 Che was right it was amazing
having T stayed in touch with him the
last year unbelievable guy you found a
gem in him um but seriously I just
appreciate you everything thank you so
much two go jet um any chance I just
made a podcast with my friends would you
be on the fifth one if I reach out to
Tyler 55 55 okay if I reach out to Tyler
I appreciate itot go jets go jet take
care good to see you bro how you been
good J man it's good to see you again
good uh listen I just got to tell you so
remember the last time I was telling you
I was working on a TV show got my final
production meeting this Friday it's
going to shop next week so that's what's
up great to see you again great to see
you that was a fun meeting with you guys
so much the crew goodw is in February
now no no the crew that came with you
yeah but it's funny this watch company
in vict I don't know if you ever heard
of that we used to work for them for a
while they hired me to MC in February
like I've never [__] done that before
so good for you br I just want to come 5
minutes so
glad got it perfect and listen buddy of
mine was in line they r a driving
company they wanted me to do that Shir
got it medium perfect awesome bro great
to see you take care stay well how you
doing I'm really well Parker Parker such
a pleasure uh thanks for doing this by
the way happy to do it uh three uh quick
things one I do want a recommendation on
P ggio for okay for Thanksgiving um uh
two I just think it's great uh
yeah Obby Obby can you find Obby can you
find Sam or
Brandon oh perfect uh Sam the Shan's
going to need a penio recommendation
awesome uh appreciate it uh two I just
think it's awesome what you're doing on
a on a level of put positivity out there
and makeing it louder than negativity I
gr around a bunch of negativity so in my
own small way I try to try to do that's
awesome um and then thirdly I just
wondered if I could pick your brain for
two seconds I'm in a grad program at at
Georgetown and created this product that
is a a first version prototype but
essentially so kind of basic but uh it's
going to hold uh reasonable grocery bags
so with the goal of taking TR supp
plastic bags out of the wa stream and I
need to find a way to get it from there
to the market and iterate um iterate um
some product design and getting it
bootstrapping it really with nothing I'm
I'm kind of there's just not enough meat
on the bone at the moment so so you
should send that photo to me and the
photo we took together and say plastic
bag invention guy something in the
subject I've got some people to talk to
you okay that' be great can appreciate
it than to do it have a great day you to
Happy Thanksgiving dude I just want to
ask you a quick question I wait it back
online just to ask you eventually
whenever you get a second I don't know
if you can because I don't know if you
manage your own Instagram like all the
time can you follow my Instagram I'll do
it right now please I I would like the
eternal
I said it's just like work for the jet
one uh the official
[Music]
Sweeney the official s right there thank
you so much appreciate
it see you see you around brother
pleasure meeting you nice to meet you
thank you bro uh can I get a cool little
quick video with you oh we got this yeah
here I'll let you hold it you got the an
what's up everybody we're here with Gary
V the legend the one and only Gary can
we tell our viewers some good
motivational kindness empathy being the
bigger person all the stuff that nobody
wants to do is actually the key to
winning in business not stepping over
people grinding through them it's
kindness kindness always wins I love it
one last question if you had to make
your millions in our times as
Millennials or Gen X how would you start
from scratch well first of all I would
start with the mindset of not making
millions the quickest way to not make
millions is to focus on making millions
grind second I would focus on what
you're strong at the reason I talk about
garage sing flipping is I'm strong at
buying and selling whether it's Chacha
at a garage sale or whether it's
attention on social media so be
self-aware and figure out what you're
good at all right and if you don't know
like you all say I don't know go do [__]
it's all about the hustle baby can I get
a two wines red white a red and then
whatever you think I should try let's do
the Ros it's epic that I love your stuff
man I like how you have that [__] you
grind attitude bro thank you bro where
do you live I live in Hasbro Heights
love it first time in the store first
time yeah cool I'm glad you checked it
out I go to the one in sadur it's
awesome all right bro take care yourself
stay well take
care my man what's your name yeah I do I
do music full time you could sign with I
do music full time for a living I went
from being homeless that quitting my job
5 years ago and I do music full time
that's what's up bro yeah proud of you
where do you live I'm me urbany yeah
right first time in the store yeah my
first time how do you like that tank R
price I love it you right yeah I love it
yeah I got a party on uh Friday so
fresh good my dude thanks for coming
through I really wish you the best
holiday yeah bro you want me to sign
this yeah
yeah
okay it's cool um so so pretty much
right I I always tell people that um
what's good everyone yeah going to
school yep like you got you got two
sides of life you got a realist and
idealist and they always give the advice
of the realist but like when I was going
to school um high school you know uh it
was nobody to give advice for like
idealist and I feel like that's what you
do appr say hell yeah some people win in
school and some don't and if you're like
us [__] school
right all right bro I wish you well make
sure you stop that all right fam I wish
you a great holiday stay well want to go
through the line of banging out no let's
keep
going so nice to meet you sir so nice to
meet you it's a real pleasure thank you
very my name is Kai k um thank you so
much for doing this I know everybody
here appreciates it you're probably
tired as hell um no I just wanted to ask
you something if you can look at two
things for
me don't mind I'm shaking a little bit I
apologize no worries I'm starting
clothing company today it's a fresh logo
thank you so much I just want to see
what you thought [__] love it
actually but don't get hype on that cuz
that's just a subjective opinion sure I
could have hated it and it doesn't mean
anything I don't even like the Nike logo
it's worth a trillion dollars the swish
yeah I don't like it I genuinely don't
like
it I'm mean that serious with you yeah
that's the point okay like I happen to
like yours but that means zero yeah it
matters out of the 7.7 billion people
how many like it more importantly it
matters how you communicate to make me
feel something when I see it yeah it's
so the CL company is called endangered
Earth so I'm going to be given back to
endangered species so you can see the
two e and then you go down like I'm an
artist so I did that [__] good bro
I'll show you like I do that's just text
message conversation I'll make this
really quick I
apologize um but that's like some of the
work that I do it's like pho realism
really good man thank you you're
talented thank how much content are you
pulling out um well to be honest with
you I just got a Tik Tok maybe like two
days ago how often are you
posting nowhere close to enough bro
you're talented you need to put out way
more
content how often can you how much how
often can you well I mean I I sell
copers and it takes me like an hour and
a half to get to work I don't give a
[__] so it's it's kind of tough you're
going straight to excuses how long does
it Tak you to do this like an hour
[__] you need to post four times
a day all right I don't give a [__] if
you're driving an hour and a half [__]
you got 24 [__] hours yeah the [__]
are you doing on the beach in here
you're on the beach here that's the
beach go on the beach I don't give a
[__] you're at the beach here like
what's the dog that means you outside
draw bro you're talented put out content
thank you so
much so I got a Tik Tok like two days
ago you need to draw just keep drawing
yes dude you're good at it thank you
very much like draw put out four [__]
of these drawings a day thank you on Tik
Tok and Instagram and Twitter if um I
mean I hate to be that guy to ask you if
I sent you like a t-shirt to your
corporate dress I'm happy to wear it but
I don't give a [__] about I'll wear
every t-shirt every day just draw you if
you draw four times a day on all those
platforms for a year I'll wear a shirt
every day I'll give you my card my's on
the back it's great I'm not going to
call it I don't give a [__] about your
card draw four times a day post on Tik
Tok Instagram and Twitter four times a
day video yourself drawing and put that
video on YouTube it's about [__]
making content to have people aware of
you your drawings are good thank you
four times a day four times a day okay
thank you so much seriously thank you
yeah sure one two
five all right everybody let's go let's
good okay let's go
hi Hi how are
you you going to
you're
welcome how close to Miles wow did you
see my dad you got to tell him will my
dad's right there tell him
about very
inspirational picture
yeah
two and uh quick sign yes this or
[Music]
this thank you tell my dad he'll love it
I love it where you were you you said
your dad's from there yeah yeah but you
were born here no I'm also from I came
back at yday you got to tell him you got
to tell him he he's right
there hey how you doing how are you I'm
really well lson such a pleasure toet
happy holiday yeah I'm a filmmaker and
you're a filmmaker yeah all right I just
didn't here yeah yeah yeah I did a a
first film ulyses actually this this is
the short story if you want I can send
you a trailer to it I'd love to see it
yeah I'll send you a trailer right after
Gary of media I'd love to see your
trailer um I'm currently doing my second
film right now and I actually plan to
use Tik Tok to help that smart I never
knew what it was before until I tell her
you talking about it and they said you
know what I can use it to get to the
market I love it where do you live
morone I love it all right 1 2
5 have the best holiday thanks for
coming through take
care hi hi thank you for being who you
are thank you for saying that thank you
what's your name Eddie
pH one two one two five that was
awesome I like look clearly you're like
[__] these
glasses wish you well where do you live
uh Cranford oh really close yeah that's
awesome first time in store yes pretty
cool huh yes can I one question for
seconds I have internship in marketing
right now it's in the marketing
department of an accounting firm but it
allows no creativity and I don't like it
it's more of a business operations thing
than a marketing thing um it ends in
January and I have no idea what to do
and I'm 26 and I'm very very lost and
don't know what's going on take that
photo email that to Gary V media Gary at
Vayner media in the subject line say I'm
the one who's in the marketing
department that doesn't know what to do
at 26
and I will set you up with some stuff
appreciate it thank you
so I love you I love you I listen to you
all the time I have three boys 219 17 is
my oldest son you've inspired them so
much all three of them have become
entrepreneur it's because of you my
third son now I'm going to give you a
[__] doesn't want to go to college
anymore CU he wants to be an
entrepreneur but I'm okay with that I
get my middle son is a soccer player in
uh Europe professional soccer player but
he does record online he went played
soccer and record I need you to give him
a shout out so I will can you give let's
first do a photo okay oh
yeah bring me the phone okay his name is
Georgie Angel yeah AB he introduced you
to us like many years
ago all right Georgie listen Mom's here
she's fired up bro's here I mean you
intro me to This Crew this is your fault
Georgie good luck keep going yeah
you great to me great engineer works for
Apple but invented like a artificial
intelligence soccer
clate where where do you live uh I live
so I go to school in Atlanta right now
but we live in Westfield awesome yeah
yeah yeah we live in Westfield and um I
just wanted to tell you like even if
people don't do what you say every
morning they wake up with Hope and Faith
because of you you do that to us I brush
my teeth I listen to you I make my
coffee I listen to you cuz I have no
time I'm on my fourth business and I'm
going to do the 4D VOR media so I'll see
you there wait I love you thank you
Happy Thanksgiving family have a great
thanks congratulations to your
parents great have a happy take care
what's good bro dude your team is
playing crazy good bro sorry about J
Dude you the the Niners are playing fire
I know man what's your name bro uh Mike
Mike where do you live bro uh in Jersey
right over here uh New
Milford um I'm into uh selling coffee
like I'm I'm a chef since I was like
okay um how what's like a one pointer I
can like start on actually are you
selling it direct to consumer or to
businesses no just straight up like
friends and family right now I actually
have a card can I give it mind bro it's
content I don't know Instagram Tik Tok
making content the [__] I put out for
free every day yeah it's that one two
five if you don't make if you don't make
nobody's going to know grab it stay well
Mike have a great
holiday got you hey man how are you what
a pleasure it is good to see you good to
meet you man how are you good Gary I
brought you something man give me one
sec
sure one one second I'm so I play in a
band from Bloomfield man I just wanted
you to have one of our shows I [__]
love that pick which one you like and
it's yours man this one cool
uh yeah all right then cool thank you
bro I wish you a photo yeah sure sure
Video One
three thank you stay well hey thank you
for everything man love the videos thank
you
bro that one is a real important
one thank you I just wanted to say thank
you maybe give you a hug happy holidays
thank you happy holidays
for yes
please thank you thank
Youk what's good I was in the one
texting you like yo let me train you for
free man I've been doing all that stff
um I got you two things one shirt from
my business and a Macho Man Randy Savage
shirt that's my favorite wrestler ever
what's your name Martin Martin real
pleasure bro yeah yeah I'm into uh take
this photo clearly you're [__]
machine one two
three yeah like listen if you ever
needed anyone travel with you anything
hit Mike panti Mike panti you'll find
him he was the guy that trained me for a
minute okay Mike banti got cuz he's
going to be looking for somebody for me
for next year got man Mike banti if you
can't figure that out you can't be my
guy anyway Mike be got it all right bro
stay well thank you happy holidays all
how are you I'm well how are you for
real here thank you brother I just want
to came here to say thank you talking
about accountability ordering time and
money and it's changed my life seriously
[__] awesome I appreciate
it what's your name Mikea where you from
um midd love it thanks for coming to the
store take care great store by the way
thank you how are you bro so I know
you're uh you're Jets fan I worked at
the American dream I'm an engineer over
oh no [__] message you a lot of times to
come and give you a tour I can't wait
see I know I know it's uh it's
crazy 1 two 5 you know I had a dream
last night that I was going to meet you
here and Mark Cuban was here and I was
cursing a lot I know you do that and he
got mad at me so he kicked me off so you
showed up in my house the next day it's
crazy it was hilarious yeah real can we
do a a little story
please sorry I'm I'm just [__]
excited to meet you I'm happy to meet
you bro
insane I want to tell them that two
legends can
coexist
Legend what's up here with my boy Gary
V why is it not
working Jesus Christ there we go here
with my boy Gary V that's me yeah that's
him you know just uh two legends CL this
the world is abundant get yours thank
you bro you're welcome bro I appreciate
it real pleasure bro how are you real
good
two yeah I just want to say thank you so
much for everything you're doing man
it's absolutely amazing bro like I'm a
high school coach now and everything all
because of you
you know I started my own podcast I love
[__] football as you see I'm Jerry
Jones but it's okay um listen can I can
you just say you know one thing on my
Instagram just like you know School
everything yo life live yours school
work Sports don't play in the system
play in your
system stay well take care yourself
man so I made a stupid ass t-shirt I
didn't think you were giving out hug so
I said man how do I get a hug right so I
said read the bottom of it though you
know like Roger Goodell style you know
what I'm saying my man the big one the
big one listen I've been following you
for 100 days you literally changed my
life in 100 days no [__] my man no
[__] not that I didn't know who you
were before but did you started really
listening really I open my ears every
day every day every single day listen so
the real
question um I'm in my own pressure
washing business again I had one in
South Florida right I've been back up
here for just about a year how do I
become the door too King dude it's you
know the way you do it is by not being
impatient I'm impatient all the time
that's your problem so I got to ground
myself that's it bro you know how to do
it you just don't want to eat the dirt
for 2 years you know exactly how to get
there cuz you did it the problem is you
want to do it faster this time you know
something I've learned something Pain's
been my ultimate PR of Mission 100% bro
my whole new life bro pain and dirt
that's that's the game that that
adversity is your strength the only
vulnerability is
impatience I'm going to keep listen
listen thank you you got it bro happy
holiday that P is fire by the way I've
been eating ity I saw your dad last
thank you
bro how are you I'm extremely well how
are you I'm good I just want to say
thank you first of all I'm really
nervous now but you've really done so
much for me um I wanted to have you sign
this I started my own car detailing
business good for you thank you you're
welcome and just one thing I want to ask
I obviously listen to you a lot but and
I listen to like about the thing about
the parents not supporting me whenever
they support me but they always kind of
like jab jokes and like oh like like my
oh yeah and it's like the thing is I
know my dad and my dad is like doesn't
believe in me and that's cool whatever
but I don't want to like talk to them
about it when they're not going to like
don't talk to better so just like [__]
off with that yeah just limit it cuz
then they're like on my ass like what
are you doing why you school do you do
you live in their home yes you got to
get out I know that's what I'm trying to
do don't try do it yes find a roommate
crash at a friend's house like go more
humble and live in a shitty shitty
shitty [__]
place you understand I do you're so
young like like [__] get dirty get
[__] and that's what I like to do
because so just like get the [__] out of
here the car detailing is the only thing
that I've really been like that's
[__] awesome so go just go find a
safe but shitty place to right or a
friend's
couch right I really appr that will help
you cuz then you won't hear the
negativity that's all that [__] I know
what you're hearing why the [__] do you
why do you think I'm telling you that a
shitty couch on a friend's house is
better than that I know so hard but I
really do appreciate it it's not hard
it's what's hard is what you're doing
doing now going into a place that you
know when you're opening the door
negativity is going to hit you in the
face what's not hard is going in a place
that might be a shitty looking place but
it's [__] positive right that's
easy thank you man you're welcome
appreciate it one last question you got
a favorite red wine I say they pick up I
got a lot of favorite red wines let me
take this photo oh
two thank you you're
welcome you want to sign it yes Happy
Thanksgiving
for two years for real you've been like
I know to you I'm just like your fan
here but for real you're a big deal to
me you really I got two main questions
today
um the happiness thing I push happiness
for me that's success but like there's a
part of my head ever since I was young
it can't be this is really important
happiness cannot be the success cuz then
what the process of trying to become
successful has to be the happiness cuz
if it's success then you're [__] [__]
sad that every minute you're not a
millionaire or have a BMW or have a
[__] a benzo you're [__] sad it's
got to be the process it's got to be the
process when I was in this store 20
years ago 15 years ago grinding M that
was the happy part got like you guys
walking in and me carrying a [__] two
you got to love the process if I was if
it was about what I am now I would have
lost what I was going to say of course
dude that's why everyone's impatient
because they want the success the affir
the [__] to show people that they won
the second you don't give a [__] about
what they think is the second you don't
have to do that is the second you find
the process you like and then
miraculously 10 years later you do have
the success it's all mind how you get
there you practice you [__] practice
and just do you [__] rewatch this
video 5,000 times that's what I'm going
to do dude it all comes down to
insecurity people want success to show
people mhm 100% I know
100% second question thank you welcome
you say that forget about your parents
cuz my mom's the you know first woman in
her family to go to college she [__]
owns a law fir she did it she wants me
to be Dr lawyer I'm an artist you do
that it's not me you can't you can't
live my mom you can do you want to do
you want to love your mom or do you want
to hate your mom I I'll always love my
Mom do you want to love your mom or do
you want to hate your mom love my Mom
good you doing what she wants you to do
is the easiest way for you to hate your
mom not love your mom you got to
disappoint her in the short term to love
her for the rest of your life and on my
end I got on my end what about your end
cuz I just feel like you know God forbid
something happens to her yeah dude God
God forbid something happens bro if you
think your mom's happiness hinges on you
being a doctor or lawyer you're so
confused you don't even know I am I know
you are everybody is people think that
they say what that's because parents are
defense mhm that's what she knows cuz
she came from being the first in her
family and that's what worked for her
yeah she's making a mistake of imposing
that on you but she's doing the best she
she loves you I know I know but the
biggest way you can let her down is by
listening to her mhm cuz you're going to
resent her I know I'm right it's pain in
the short term but long term you guys
are going to be closer she's going to
love you regardless in the
end cool thank you guys you're welcome
BR a big deal for me appreciate it one
oh one two
5 take care bro you got it D what up how
are you I'm good I just want to say
thank
[Music]
you say thank you I appreciate it cuz
like you inspired me to do a lot now I'm
going to Samoa to study [__] make a
documentary out there good for you bro
appreciate it real pleasure I was weing
my roommate obsessed with you he's right
now cuz you shout out him out what's his
name
Matthew Matt Matt I'm super upset that
you're not here with us I'm here with
your homies got a great [__] fro
going I'm [__] pissed that you're not
here bro but next time next time Matt
keep pushing thanks for listening Matt
love you thank you so you're welcome bro
appreciate it yeah happy to do it take
care of yourself you too God bless all
right fellas take care of
yourself
yo yeah how's everything downstairs good
calm yeah good what's up brother nice to
meet you man such a pleasure bro nice to
meet you man bro it's great to see you
how are you man listen I got to be
honest man he sent me pictures of you
there's pictures in certain lighting
yeah where we look like identical like I
know we don't really look no I can see
it though a little bit like when you
wear this
when yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so where
you come uh Staten Island New York the
universe was telling him come see you
today I'm super glad man yeah I'm glad
you're here I left my wallet in his car
last night and like obviously I didn't
want to drive to Jersey today craziness
but then he's like yo Gary V is at the
I'm like guess I got get your wallet get
your wallet back got the [__] wallet
back so he need some adice Sor he just
wrote a book yeah yeah yeah good for you
bro yeah man I so I don't know give me
like 30 seconds I'll give you 50 seconds
the uh the uh the the answer I'm so
consistent with this the only way I
think there's two ways the lots of money
way then no money way they're both
actually the same game which is in
today's world creating cont content in
written audio or visual form and posting
them on the 10 platforms is the [__]
I'm a broken [__] record but it's the
actual answer yeah the question becomes
why people don't post that's the big
question you're right why aren't you
posting a LinkedIn holding back correct
it's usually judgment then the question
becomes from whom right like are you
worried about your [__] parents in
your boys your girls I'll give you part
of the answer I'm a teacher so you're
worried School Syl pres my whole online
presence issol there I don't have any of
it but I just I decided like I just made
a Twitter a week ago I'm like [__] it
man I'm no the school's not going to
kick you out you're not going to kick me
out don't say dumb [__] no no no I get
it I get I'm with you you know what I
mean people like oh [__] 10 years ago my
principal was I can't tell you to do it
not do it kid were like friending me on
Facebook that's different dude 10 years
ago the world was different no you're
right everybody now knows you're right
now it's like go no I'm there man all
right bro have the best holiday can you
sign my I sure can I'm going to bring
this to Thanksgiving and I'm going to be
like two quick things for
you you're welcome bro my uh my aunt
works for the PGA Tour yes de EV and
stuff y one two five a you deal with
like what win would you want to try to
get 100% got you and uh my phone so you
met a good friend of mine recently my
friend uh charm charm remind me remind
me again she's like Indian Filipino girl
oh yes yeah I've been telling her like
you should make a vodka we do all these
events like so it'd be funny for you had
a selfie video where you're like why
isn't your average social
VOD it so we're at the Wine Library we
sell a fuckload of vodka here and I
don't know what do you think like I
think there's a big problem I think I
think we're missing we're missing we're
missing the average socialite
Voda I'm sad it doesn't exist we would
sell tons of
cases [__] act
right my man always you bro it's great
to see you take care yourself real
pleasure man Post Yeah Yeah i'me man all
right bro see take care all right thank
you
guys good to see you br how you been
good great to see you how are you great
to see
you z um so I just uh one question would
you mind if I give you a little bit of
context pleas she's here to answer when
I know it so I just I go to high school
here in Springfield awesome so um yeah
yeah it's uh I'm in my junior year right
now um and I've I've been able to put
myself in a position where I can get
into a really good college and have a
good future set up for me okay but the
thing is I'm not entirely enthusiastic
about school I enjoy you know things
like the hustle I I found a love for you
know content creation I did for a while
I found like a small streaming platform
worked for about a year and a half kep
being yeah uh for about a year and a
half I did streaming until I actually
blew up and then they changed their
business model worked with them for a
while I got a lot of networking and a
lot of connection through that but in
the end have you debated the concept of
both of both school
and it's been tough because I have to or
not have to but I'm expected to and I
expect myself I'm going to put 100
whatever I'm doing I'm going to put 100%
into that why don't you put 100 into
both well to maintain a little bit of
sleep as well of course of course but I
mean here here's here's where I'm going
with it if you have the ability to be
the kind of student that you're talking
about I didn't have that ability I was
so over indexing in One
Direction but the reality is is that the
the thing that you're looking for in
life that could happen because of your
roommate at Duke or brown not because
you [__] hustled 24 hours a day I I
think the world's interesting I think
the
both I mean that meaning I mean what's
the debate here is the debate to not go
to college and go fully in
entrepreneurship no no that's not
debatable I'll tell you that much father
so what's what's the question I've just
been doing a lot of different things you
know so I found that other than School
I've found the passion in content
creation and business that's awesome so
my my question for you is would you ever
be willing to let me shadow you for a
day because I want that experience yeah
you're can to get in touch with to done
summer done I really appreciate it man
you're
welcome appreciate I'm just here support
I've been doing I've been doing uh telom
and media for 20 years before Time
Warner with America so all the
executives way like on the Discovery
digitals I said if that's your passion
when you're ready but I won't do the
intros for so he has to show I'm just a
driver tonight smart and I said make
himn it I think that's super smart
smart he he's putting you in the right
position taste for it he'll figure it
out he has to run through the for 100%
when you hand it to them they don't
understand that's hug I didn't even
given them anything everything he's
done what's your name Yuri Yuri nice to
meet you where do you live my parents
from from a Floren Park very nice yeah
hi hi Victoria Victoria how are
you I mean I wanted to ask you um I was
I was
a 13 years okay and I left the for
America and I started my own coaching
business good for real um so I'm doing
services and I'm going to coach I'm work
in progress myself but I'm going to
coach um other Finance people out yeah
yeah okay yeah I'm going to give them
that model also any any kind of advice
um all the content that you put out
don't put it out as a gateway to the
service put it out to bring do not put
out content that's intent is to get
people to subscribe to your coaching put
out content that is just good
content and then it's more likely for
you to get coaching
clients okay coaching clients you mean
to get uh for finance or for
service um for finance professionals cuz
I want to give the finance people an
opportunity that opportunity so they can
do the same thing I'm doing I understand
so you're talking about that correct
okay when you're putting out a video on
LinkedIn to finance people yeah don't
make it a sales pitch
yeah okay that's where everybody loses
yeah okay nobody wants to see your sales
pitch yeah no I know I know that's why
people consume my content it's not a
sales pitch yeah I don't want thing from
you which then leads to people wanting
to do things with you yeah okay
[Music]
awesome
sure
ready
awesome thank you have a wonderful
Thanksgiving thanks for coming you got
it take care
bye-bye how are you this is cute Zion
what's good you okay yeah okay good
Natalia hi Natalia how are you and this
is Colin Colin what's good bro I like
that Batman hoodie thank you my name is
Anthony it's my wife nice to meet you
what's your name
tab my brother-in-law how are you nice
to meet you no nice to meet you thanks
for
coming thank you for having us man
thanks for coming such an influence
thank you I guess since I'm here I want
to save some of your time I don't want
to go on too long um first thing I'd
like to say again besides thank you is
U specifically about self-awareness I
think
uh I think you say what you say about
self-awareness but I think very few
people pick it up as as well as what you
realize I've listened to you talk about
you know thank you bro going into the
bathroom at a time and getting to
yourself and re charging or the concept
of like as a cat you licked yourself to
you know clean up you know for your own
mind um I'm really deep into your
content one thing that uh I've noticed
and appreciate it was when you were
talking to a recent CEO I don't remember
exactly who it was but you
really you really leaned in to get him
to understand the accountability that
you're trying to get to and I think you
were like specific until like where you
can actually reach him with
that I was as a thank you for some of
the Insight that I've gotten through
self-awareness I would also like to uh
provide value towards you in the way
that you like to say go selfish and how
it gives you more media and things along
those lines I like to give you some more
value in that sense of asking you know
for people that come from a little bit
of my background with the message itself
awareness that you push out for you to
lean in a little bit with that message
cuz it's been so helpful for me it makes
me happy it really has you know uh you
know I garden and I can find times where
I'm in peace and there and things along
those lines you know uh raising two kids
is it's not e it's real stuff you we
live in h New Jersey in hi in Township
yes I know it yeah um so you know my
thing is I like cooking I like to eat
health and things along those lines we
we all have a garden we all love plants
one day I would love to send you uh a
English sugar snap I'm in send you the
pl my kids kids grow Snap please we have
a bunch of snap pleas learning how to do
it and everything like that um
so I come from a background where uh you
know a little bit of a broken family
things along those lines um but one
thing I've noticed is a lot of people in
my family with our background don't
really know how to take a step into
business and um my my goal one day is to
kind of kind of bring that in your
terminology friction that friction from
it's I think it's an emotional thing
it's 100% emotional looking at like
taxes the the the the details are on
Google right exactly everything's on
Google everything's emotional everything
the information is a commodity how do I
pay my taxes Google enter it's all this
I have a 70-year-old Aunt who just won
an award for making like this great mac
and cheese awes and she doesn't she she
she doesn't know what to do to get
started with the business she's afraid
of the health department she's afraid of
everything all defense all defense all
fi I get it so you know I'm trying to
make something for myself for the family
for love it future um my idea for a
product is to create hemp butter great I
get it I know the space right so I don't
know what I'm doing you know um
everything is Imagination going out
nobody knows what they're doing until
they do it exactly you said everything's
scary until dude no I didn't know how to
do anything that I'm doing I didn't know
how to write a book I didn't know how to
make videos I didn't know how to
anything here's my label with it myself
it's great bro good for you working it
out I appreciate you when you have a
package up when you have one send it to
me I'll help you thank you so much welc
let's take the photo get in here crew
yes you in who's got the
camera tck what time is
it
no you want me to tell them you're
leaving in 5 minutes no thank you
how many times
thats cool
yeah thank you you're welcome listen to
him he's going to tell you to listen to
his content
man bro negativity no matter where it
comes from is always
always I promise you I promise you if
you focus find go find positive real
[__] because smoking you doesn't mean
[__] negative parents doesn't mean [__]
just focus it's all look for the
positivity I promise you it's [__]
thank thank than bro love you guys hi
it's my birthday happy birthday and
there's nowhere else I wanted to be here
thank you for being one of my five
people that I listen to for you've
elevated my like whole existence um I'm
the CEO of Kidville and so I just have
been like a huge fan of your work
congrats your success thank you so much
you really like with the fire under my
ass to get it [__] moving keep going
thank you we're wait hold on I got to
give a camera and shook hold
on so official one two
five thank you one two five thank you
granford I love that I'm a un girl thank
you so much great to see you take care
what's up crew yes I'm here I'm waiting
great to see you again you well here I
mean you have helped Inspire the
movement from when again thank you
brother I can't wait I can't wait to
[__] rock this dude I'm so going to
rock this I'm going to garage sale on
this
[__] app I'm 100% Going to garage sale
that Obby actually you know what I'm not
taking any chances make sure this is
make sure this isn't a car for the
garage
sale I know hi Nikki n such a pleasure
she helps keep us organized
a
woman how you guys doing not bad yeah so
why do you do the five it's a really
funny reason I am thank you
um four years ago I just was like [__]
I'm going to take a fuckload of photos
one day I want to look at them when I'm
90 I'm like I need a [__] side like I
need to do something that's like not
just like the same so then I was like
what am I going to do and I was like
[__] five like important number to me
the jet Jersey my mom kned has five five
is my number so I'm like I can do five
just started doing it and now it's like
a real thing cool can we get a quick
video shout out just the Jet fans
yes ready 1 2 3 oh you're not so mad now
anymore right we've won three in a row
everyone's calmed a little bit down with
the [__] helicopters fire gaze here's
why fans are impatient this a new regime
give it a little [__]
time through a lot of [__] I get it I
know you're impatient but patience is
the only way when you have the right GM
and you have the right quarterback you
always are in a spot I'm real pumped
about that and honestly I've been on it
I've been public about it on Twitter I'm
about gaze too and it may or may not
work out but we need to be patient we
[__] have 800 injuries we're on our
[__] seventh and eighth and Ninth
[__] linebacker calm the [__] down
let's go Jess
baby BL man thanks for inspiring have a
great great holiday you hey good to see
you good to see you you I just started a
running organization called every mile
is a gift and ESP thanks to you because
of gratitude process and then I have one
question is I want to start a business
of connecting people
um actually want a video for the morning
I want you to give me P toop for the
future that I'll K watch every day
listen there's only one pep talk if you
don't love your process you've got no
shot so hustling is a lot easier when
you love it so please just keep loving
it and if you don't and if you don't
love what you're doing in four years and
you look a little different and I look a
little different if you don't love it
[__] change it all right got it thank
you you're welcome I didn't know if you
wanted that f f thank you he's
definitely not going to not take
it real pleasure how are you I just
wanted to say uh thanks for everything I
love you dude I love you what's your
name Luigi Luigi where do you live uh
Oldbridge I just came from Edison
actually I it s working on Amazon but
that's what's up oh [__] a photo crazy
man one two two
five Happy Thanksgiving bro thanks for
take care love you
[Music]
back this is little Rick Rick how are
you see Santa Claus whoa thank you
do you flip oh he's I love it
photo who's that one two three a thank
you so much good good Gary could we do a
um like a trash talk I know you're in
Jersey you're right by we we'll be able
to do something like a podcast or
something we will absolutely do
something this I'm ready I'm happy to do
it I want to do it beautiful making
sense nothing and everything makes sense
I'd like to do it J you know what I mean
and I we I'd love to give you some
exposure take
care you're probably not it's been a
little bit of a day yeah I know sorry I
won't keep you too long you won't Lisa
lock um you're a [__] inspiration
thank you I am launching a a recruiting
firm whenever I need to grind away I
just put on your podcast thank you I
just had a baby congratulations you look
amazing lost my job when I was pregnant
so it's like I don't have anything to go
back to so I'm like [__] I I'm want to
launch my own F good for you how you
feel thank you because of you you acted
on
it photo where do you live uh in one C
all right one two three four five how's
the uh firm doing we have a good
start uh I did the website once my
husband's like looks like [__] looks
like a [__] Blog start over so I
started over launching it this week
hopefully hopefully good luck thanks
take care take
care oh what's going on again bro how
are you man good thanks appreciate you
staying and hanging out for
this
you so I just I will talk your ear if I
wanted to give you a couple things real
quick here's my side hustle business
card here's my my work business card one
of my clients it's to gym in Fairfield
if you ever want to train anywhere this
is my side project cat fluence it's a
page for cat influencers I love it I
just launched a website have some merch
on there trying to little Bub's on fire
huh little Bub yeah yeah that's a big
one uh but yeah I've been doing it for
like two and a half years now building
an audience now I just launch some merch
try to make some money on it I do want
to give you one of as well appreciate
the
time so just how you're you're
determined to own the Jets I know you
will I'm determined to work for you you
or barcel whoever sco me up first but
I'm determined you do I work in digital
marketing what uh I do Consulting right
now but
SEO uh social help websites on on uh
okay all it you do content you do search
you do building do content and search as
well L link building affiliate
little to connect with you some wish you
bro have of course photo yep two a how
are you doing good so huge rest hug F
thank you and uh
so um yeah so two I want to be thankful
to you for like two things so I'm a
software developer at Capital One and uh
wanted to do something by myself
interested in Fitness and all that so
started watching your content 3 years
ago and uh when I didn't have a job I
was searching job searching
so I saw your flipping videos and all
that so I just started randomly my first
garage
sale oh your first garage sale yeah
firstage first one what
happened I got a Majong game yes 1974
yes $1 Yes sold it for 250 Jesus I mean
the shipping yeah yeah of course it came
to 175 something but this was my first
and the very first house not even like
the that's crazy the first house I
stopped the yard sale app
I go in I I see I I knew that was
something vintage I it up you thought it
was old I looked it
up and even like M&M mugs and all that
which I thought wouldn't even sell
everything was
sold and then I got a job and all that
but I still like think I can always go
back to it because of that one
experience I love it bro second thing
documenting yes so since I cannot just
leave my jobs to
and all that I was like let's start
showing people the process yes love it
so uh recently turned vegan since like
30 days it's been 30 days how you
feeling perfect yeah so from day one
started putting out love it my weight
yep my body whatever so posting my
workouts every day and uh Instagram
stories in the form of highlights on
whatever I'm eating even though it's
like a boring process same things don't
highlights don't do stories put it in
put it in uh so it's saved in highlights
yes day
one love yes and uh my post in the
workouts I even though I eat the same
things every day meal prep but people
are still that's what I have to show
right and it's the truth and the day
before yesterday I was reading a podcast
where you said the same thing like 20%
will be boring yep but you get I it
clicks always I a great Thanksgiving I
have one more question please because
I'm running late yeah sorry uh So
currently I'm happy with my mind know
that documenting will help me leave my
job one day but uh my girlfriend's
parents I mean they're like if you guys
want to marry they're okay with that but
are you not listening I'm not listening
cuz that's the answer to your question
anything that starts with but my
girlfriend's parents means
this even if it means she wouldn't be
able to marry me because if they don't
let her marry me real dating so what are
you going to
do eventually I'll be frustrated and all
that but how should I what do they want
from you to be in software developer and
keep earning that money so do that I
told them good good do that tell them
you're going to do that marry the
daughter and then change your mind I was
think I'll see you later all right
brother take
care you like that that was so
good best daughter good to see Seth
couldn't come cuz he was on iHeart but
he wanted us to send his regards and to
see you we live so close so we were like
let's run over I'm glad you did take a
quick picture come let's do
it one two five aome thank you it's
great to see guys please say hi to him
for me will you to see getting with
Marcus a little bit we were working with
I do cook products licensing yes and so
I reached out to him reach out to me and
update me if there's anything that's
clunky I work with of your teams we do
Oreo and we do Planters so there's been
so much VOR media in my life aome so
cool awesome have a great Thanksgiving
byee we work on overtime Mis I'm aware
dad you know I know to be at
6 almost
7 how are you good to see you good to
see you it's real pleasure pleas we're
not selling wine I could sell more wine
if I stood downstairs for one
minute it's a pleasure bro pleasure yeah
what do you live uh I live in the ocean
awesome thanks for the drive up yeah
it's a real pleasure thank you for
coming anytime yeah it's like it's like
meeting Jim R you know thank you brother
it's a real pleasure I wish you the best
oh thank you anything I can answer for
you you're good
um actually I was curious of uh
I guess openings in your London uh
office yeah well not for me for my
girlfriend she lives in Scotland have
her sent me an email to the link of the
openings and I'm happy to help have her
attach that photo she can do anything
with the lens I love it thank you bro
thank you very much you're welcome have
a good night you too have a great
Thanksgiving hey Gary Dan Marshall Dan
such a pleasure likewise I've come all
the way from Atlanta to pay respects to
the god father of empathy you're very
sweet by way of East wetherford my
wife's a Jersey girl you guys live in
Atlanta right now you here for the
holiday yeah glad sister and uh I turned
her on to you from the uh the garage
sale fliping and now she's bought in I
love it hey um I wanted to show you I I
we were listen to your podcast and
education I used to teach people how to
make records in college and I quit that
job a while ago now I'm doing a
streaming show sort of like Bob Ross in
the studio where we show all the
mistakes and the warts and everything I
love it D and uh so I I've taken kind of
your concept of let it go early show the
process the documentation yeah so I call
it completionism I think you might have
called it that but uh it's awesome I've
done one Tik Tok video about it would
you help me out with the second one I
will
okay hey it's Sensei Hollywood I'm here
with the Gary ve The Godfather of
empathy thank you Gary when it comes to
music making yes why is completionism
greater than perfectionism because
perfectionism is actually disguised for
insecurity and completionism is actually
putting out your music you heard it here
from the man Gary V thank you so much
thank you brother thank you happy happy
holidays hey what's a good red for a
turkey day um there's a PE yeah hey Dad
Dad
oh oh Pop Sam what's a good r k k Pino
Kino go okay thank you so much for your
time stay
well nice to meet
you Brian I like
it this is an awesome surprise thank you
we work for a law firm over in Chad of
New Jersey um MC Freeman Nara and we've
actually done some work for media but
yeah so we're big into um emotional
intelligence harassment trainings and
all that so like I you know I follow
everything you do we're really pushing
really
y he's a 49ers fan though issue right
you know it doesn't bother the Jets
doesn't bother us they're not a problem
for us one Garrison Hurst 1998 96 y
touchdown in over time you know what
happened there I was in hun in County
New Jersey he did that overtime run I
jumped in my car and drove to Boston cuz
I was so upset literally jumped in my
car and drove to Boston I had a
girlfriend there like f i remember it's
awesome photo yeah man definitely
definitely one two five over there awes
thank you hope you guys have a great
holiday thanks for stopping in yeah real
place where do you guys live I live in
Hoboken and you and I'm in Cranford love
it have you ever been to the store
before I have not pretty crazy right
we're off literally like 5 minutes away
[__] crazy I been here and power Le
was like yeah the place is dope she
actually recommended the
Chiefs yeah take care take
care how are you good yeah real good
brother good I mean you helped me and my
mom out so much this is actually her
book that she made so nice H it was
you've been helping me
out where I'm at now what's your name
Jack Jack thank you bro thank you so
much yeah get a picture ready one two
five one two five thank you where do you
live Livingston awesome man thanks for
coming through glad you saw
it
how are you good good thank you happy to
look at
it real pleasure let take a photo all
right one two
five oh help be M just like you
do the idea is pretty much helping the
consum with the cars and putting it
together making it s for him I get it
can't wait to take a look one more
photo camera is a little one two
[Music]
three I'm happy to take a look happy
holiday can't
wait than you're welcome no no worries
at all I'm I'm sick I don't worries
thank you for that um I wanted to know
um if I could send you some stuff sure
um I have a company that's going to drop
some clothes we start we open in like
two days can't wait to check it yeah so
send it okay I'll send send it to the
office we we get it any uh words advice
y patience bro when you start something
new if
patience it's so fun to give the
patience talk here because this is where
I did my patience in this store patience
bro it's going to take a decade if you
think about how good the Brand's going
to do next week you lost if you think
about how it's going to do in a decade
you got a shot got you appreciate it do
you have a PE thank you do you have a PE
box I send it to no it's 10 it's you
know what send me an email to Gary ofner
media and I'll give you I'll put you in
touch with my one of my admins and
they'll get it set up proper Okay g what
at Vayner media Gary ater media.com
thank you appreciate BR happy holiday
thank you you too going to say leaving
to a fellow Russian to make people stand
in line thank you bro a give this is
this a gift for you this is from Israel
Boutique wine it's actually not here
understood the way that I got to import
this was my partner and I we did
basically you appreciate this free
marketing for all these guys for 2 and a
half years and then these guys saw us
online and said by the way do you guys
import we said well we do like maybe so
love that what's your name Greg Greg
real pleasure yeah um I wanted you to
actually one
second my this is my friend actually
this is her book
she's how are you join we're
live such a pleasure I'm Esther I'm the
one that keeps tagging you my husband
was like this guy hasn't blocked you yet
and then you replied to me and I told
him no bamin no and I told him you see I
would get that reply I did the selfie
with your dad you so much here been on
it um eat the ice cream boy don't break
my books
photo oh it's good you
good one two
three 1 two three I love it where do you
guys live I live in Fon and I live in
Livingston I love it a quick video about
Israeli wine I just want to your opinion
about what's happening
with so my take on Israeli wines is
super simple which is it is very clear
that the Tera in the region is
remarkable and can make world class
wines it's taken the region a long time
to kind of come from that perspective
that level of patience putting in the
proper wine making obviously there needs
to create more demand for the product to
really go all the way there but it's
very clear the quality is world class
awesome man thank you bro thank you have
a great holiday you too I wanted to get
your opinion on something so I know
you're big into music do you listen to
to Hip Hop or I don't are you familiar
with high-end audio I am okay so this is
my dad's brand my dad like your dad came
here not as early so this is my house
system set up sh though um my dad
unfortunately had a last I know thank
you and I know you talk about so I felt
like when I listen to some of your
podcast that's one of the things that
you said that's your only par right so
I'm start my dad and I differed in
business in like our point of view he
was doing this like he's one of the top
10 acoustic engineers in the world he
didn't want to go into lifestyle Market
where I said that's where it's at and I
saw by the way
I don't want to use cuz you I listen to
you and I try not to use the f word
right but then I'm like I don't give an
f what other brands tried I believe
because I used to do fundraising and I
have um whatever like Eugene R for
instance I ran a project for him when I
was in fundraising um he spoke at rage
where I used to work whatever I have an
inam please bam look this is Dad Gary
who Mama listens to
right T Rock T Rock it's a very simple
game put yourself out of business before
somebody else does it for you oh right
gosh I did it that's right okay so long
story short okay I now that my dad's n
well in a way I don't want to say off
for bits of blessing in disguise you're
now your but I'm able right so I'm
expanding into a different Market okay
and um I was wondering not God bless you
not really the forum for it and you have
so many people waiting if you would take
my invitation whenever you're around cuz
we're 10 minutes from here so come
listen send me an email I'll take list
yeah it'll have to be random whenever's
good for you okay you so much it was a
pleasure to meet you and I love I just
listen to when you say that you're this
is what I'm making my husband listen cuz
we run I help them run our retail
operation he does like Vape CBD
distribution then you're the general the
niess factor people like I just Rel
listen and it's like so brilliant like
what you said like the commodity you
could buy certain things from people but
it's hot and I tell my husband listen
all the time and he made I just have to
show you really quickly really
really oh sorry okay I'm going to send
it to you he made a video for Youk thank
you much thank you bye
bye nice to meet you you help me Liz
help me help me I want to show you a
message real quick I know you can't get
to everyone that was when you you on the
P thank you brother so thank you so much
photo
yes all right 1 two 5 beautiful awesome
guys one more for the bus I get
that fine I it fine generating leads I
mean content I know there's two ways of
generating leads grinding it in sales
cold call cold emails kit brand produce
so much value to people that they reach
out to you that's it nothing in the
middle grind sales pound brand value it
comes real estate that's was the one who
helped me out I she help me out to get
exempt for New York license so that's
awesome it's awesome awesome have a
great holiday take care yes you
too what is it again it's uh Ethan Jack
bman right there you rock thank you g
you're welcome oh my God this is such a
pleasure such an honor to meet you I
just want to say you have so much energy
I've been waiting like for an hour and a
half and I every person that has left
has been smiling like beaming so thank
you so much you're an inspiration I'm 31
years old and I I I wanted to finish
your book over break but um I wanted to
say that I've been in a finance job like
9 to5 jobs and after hearing you and
reading everything and and watching you
you've inspired me to pursue so many
other passions like improv and standup
comedy and playing an instrument and
just doing whatever it is but pursuing
your passions and so thank you so much
you have a vibrant energy and it's such
an honor to beet you thank you where do
you live um Atlanta but my family from
Jersey so I literally flew from the
airport I came in and I was like I got I
I just want to miss him and I literally
ubered right over here just to like meet
you in person thank you so
much I hope you have the best holiday we
in jerse um what where in Jersey
Princeton oh I love that yeah awesome um
one other thing is I've also been
working on starting on my own podcast
and creating a personal brand is so
important and I think for me it's like
just putting my voice out there and
getting myself out there has been a
struggle and so you're worried about
judgment I am and I'm worried about the
hate I know and it's scary it's so scary
you have to practice so is swimming
riding a bike kissing a boy it's all
scary it is until you do it until you do
it what push you to take that leap for
me I got lucky because my whole
childhood was losing yeah I was always
so me too I was always average well then
then then you shouldn't be scared of it
yeah you need to figure out if you have
a relationship where you worry about the
parents judgment if you can if you if
you can get that right it should be
pretty good okay can you can we do a
video yeah the advice for
for I'm here with Gary B my RO model
what do you want um advice on leaping
taking leap of faith and putting
yourself out there you've done it so
many times kissing swimming uh driving
you've been scared your whole [__]
life just jump thank you welome it's
been an honor take
care G my name is Steve I'm doing great
um I was actually in Las Vegas when you
were doing a bagio at a for the mortgage
brokers how' you like that talk I loved
it thank you I was actually on after you
um later in the day I had nobody in the
room you had the place filled I had like
50 people at least you were on stage
yeah I used to I used to have 50 people
too that's what it is you got to build
up the audience um I'm a huge New York
Jets fan I love that I hope it you know
if anything you General manage it would
that be on the table for you for me yeah
no got to own it right it Own It own it
or nothing else or nothing else that's
awesome thank you brother um it's a real
pleasure it's a real pleasure I live
right down the street I'm in Springfield
so I come to Wine Library all the time
um actually I was one of the really cool
things is when I go to check out I still
see your name and an extension yes
although I know you're all over the
place he's still reachable he's still
relatable and all that thank I
appreciate that absolutely two 125 have
a great holiday thank you you too thank
you nice speak I'm his wife a huge fan
I'm Julie Julie have a great holiday you
thanks for coming here
often good to see you good to see you
all right 1 two 5 a awesome thank you
you're welcome can you help me pick out
wine from my mom 100% what do you want
to spend down What She Likes I don't
care
bro she wrote down just that word and
then she wrote down all that after like
a
minute
Trel yeah you
want me to sign
it I didn't do
it just to
be that's a that's a vad strategy
drought that's defense real quick yeah
good defense off thank you it's an
overrated fact that's true I'm a Dallas
you say that uh what's that what's that
Clark
State got get her get him a Clark Clark
State um for this the play which is
right there do you want one of these
special occasion wies I was kind of
thinking that yeah there's something no
like uh on this what's that yeah exactly
you got it appreciate you so much thank
you man a great has happened since the
last time I saw you that makes me so
happy man keep going bro you just
started uh oh good okay hi I'm going in
there going in go we're not going to
stop
you
I was at the NC event and I was seeing
you from and close where you live bro I
didn't pay the 700 not to say like that
it's way better that's why I do [__]
like this patience yes sir exactly
everything's amazing good bro I was
telling your dad like hearing the story
of how you built a business with him
it's like I believe it but when I came
here I'm like wow built an
Empire amazing
congratulate you and
everything I've been texting you see
mess I'm trying bro I'm trying I did a
thousand last night still I'm not even
close I went to um an event with Doug
Nelson he married the right
girl and like the whole mindset hack is
like completely blew me away and now
it's like what you say with patience
like I see my goal good bro I want to do
and help people love the process yeah
right awes I love the process hope you
have the best holiday bro definitely
nice me
you dude you wor me
out I want a picture holding the book or
shirt where do I buy one of these shirts
this one I don't think we have them yet
can sign it
yep
two handshake down yes sir you want a
hand we hand
handshake thanks for hanging around hey
man I'm got to get back to
West I do want to buy a bottle and a
book and a book the book you got I think
it's signed thanks for hanging you want
sign I think it's signed open it sign I
think let see no NP sorry all right real
quick yes sir a year ago I see one of
your videos and I go ah this guy's cool
he says it like it is 6 months ago my
Syracuse summer help this kid says to me
hey you got to check out this Gary V
you should quit me and and I'm meeting
with him tomorrow to do put them on my
coffee podcast I can't wait to show
that's awesome take
care have a great holiday thanks for
hanging around hey man G this is a
[__] legit gift well I know put it
down somewhere Mitch can you put can
some dad can you put this in your office
for a little while before I break
it seriously though all the advice and
everything you put out into the world
all the tips and everything and just the
mindset and like [__] like the [__] you
just said while I was online put
yourself in the business before somebody
else puts you put it there that's kind
of exactly what I'm doing like I'm
living the life that you tell me to live
not telling but advising you're
listening I'm listening I'm listening
and I'm executing and it's it's making
such a [__] difference makes me so
happy that's why I drove here from
Brooklyn to like give you this you know
what honestly you should go through that
because take the envelope out of it I
will when only have two minutes and read
it I will read every word it's I wish
you well have a great holiday thank you
brother than thanks for coming from
Brooklyn it means a lot to
me nice to meet you man great to meet
you I'm excited to read this it's a
great one it's my favorite book I ever
wrote thank you so much yeah let's take
this photo where you
from what
Parton what's that Poconos D Rock from
Poconos did you guys where yeah now
we're
out I love it cool all right thanks for
spping bro thanks for coming here means
a lot to me thank you all right my
brother how are you good to see you to
meet you pleasure you met uh my son I
sure did
cutie it's a real pleasure real pleasure
nice see you guys going to hang or just
he's picking you up we're go love I love
you more I love you nice to meet you
some content what's that can I force
some content with you and your dad come
here Dad do some
content
I'm I'll be two seconds I'm almost done
he wants to do some content come on all
right so a lot of people that follow me
are IM immigrant background Y and one of
the things I'm really curious about to
hear from you and you um a lot of
immigrants struggle saying I love you to
their parents it's just not something
they grew up I love you to their parents
or the parents of the kid or both okay
go ahead and I wanted to hear your
thoughts on both of that of like goe
that's it that's a topic I just want to
hear what you guys have to say about it
oh we're doing it where are we doing it
no care about my camera oh got
it super easy for me to answer that one
both my par a lot of times when people
hear me talk about my dad you know like
a lot of people assume like I always
give my dad a lot of credit and I'm glad
you brought this up because I don't know
if you've ever really heard this from me
I listen yeah I understand uh I you
already know the story you know like
like the the answer is my dad never
struggled with telling me I love you I
never struggled telling my parents I
love them they never struggled right now
that's the way every that's that's like
a good morning no seriously I think I
think what you're referring to is
whether it's Americans or immigrants
there's a lot of people culturally in
families who their parents didn't do for
the person that's watching you need to
take the responsibility to be the one
that broke the chain right if your
parents didn't do it if your
grandparents did it then you should know
it sucks so you should then fight fight
to be the one that starts the process I
was very fortunate I always talk about
being very lucky with my parents
situation I never had to have that issue
my parents crushed that yeah definitely
good job all right I got to get out of
here Thomas I just want to tell you
something so this is inspired by right
so while I was waiting in line I was
like every single person who's standing
in this line right now is much more
likely to be successful just by the fact
that they showed up and they're here so
I created a Facebook group and in the
whole time that you were talking to
everybody we have now 7 remembers that's
amazing good job that's
awesome Mark Mark you still look like
you in hoop a little bit what's up buddy
you're still holding it together bro
great to see you hey man I heard you
bought a pumpkin pie I did I'm very
excited about that it's good I got a
question for you someone texted me in a
question I got two questions for I sent
you a text over the summer so you want
to play Hoops did you get it I I'm not I
wish I got it check this out a fan a
friend of mine's fan had asked the
following question here so uh
I have a couple of question what he
wants to know is at this point what
motivates you to do what you do in terms
of motivating helping people at there's
nothing that feels better than
admiration ah there's nothing that what
like there's nothing that that was the
easiest 5 hours of my life okay the
admiration is intoxicating look at this
baby yeah he know he didn't know about
your
sneakers he's living his life you you
got sneaks going I got sneaks going Jeff
how are you he
bu yes Isam you charge me for a lot of
things man especially uh I love that get
going you know I left the IND for a
while came back and I'm glad you're here
brother I'm glad that took on chance
thank you brother yeah thank you for
everything 100% who's got the camera Bob
got the camera I guess I'm not taking
picture you got a camera you don't have
a phone on you phone a success always
help ready phoom come on St
great
pleasure I
know how cute is
that how C
wants
good that's a store people keep going
this more not that
one what are you
doing there some straggles she cute
right it's crazy h
can't believe you're a [__]
dad so [__]
good so happy see you in a couple weeks
wait if you try try and make it if you
can there's no try you know I haven't
met kids right none of
them 15th Sunday the
15th 15 one second then
probably 100% play Thursday
and that's it home of the location where
we did daily V number three M four years
ago CS Vegas uh that's a wrap for daily
V and I've got to be honest with you I
think the ability to know when to stop
something I had to do it with Wine
Library TV I had to do with the sary V
show the ability to know when to stop
something and innovate is crucial and I
think weekly V is going to be a monster
that is going to bring you guys a ton of
[__] value so I hope you enjoy enjoy
it thank you so much if you've been
watching it in essence daily V hasn't
been [__] daily for a while anyway
it's been two or three a week you feel
four two is that the range so it's going
to be once a week plus we're have a ton
of good news there'll be a ton of daily
content uh not a ton a daily piece of
video on uh YouTube anyway but weekly be
is going to be a beast and I hope you
become obsessed with
it